gauche de la souris sur l'emoji ou de
cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
et salut tout le monde et bienvenue pour
pour ce nouveau live j'espère que vous
allez bien on va suivre ensemble
alors attendez
on va suivre ensemble cette nouvelle
journée
de
[Musique]
champions je suis en train de réfléchir
ça parce que en fait ça se peut que en
fait j'ai pas j'ai pas attends il faut
que je fasse un petit truc fais donc
sinon ça va pas fonctionner
parce qu'en fait il faut que je mette le
focus mode
le vrai quoi pas le pédagogie
c'est exactement ça
et donc il va falloir que je fasse une
petite manip et ne vous inquiétez pas en
rater rien
le Fab est là bien évidemment je guette
tu guettes
on va on va on va y arriver
ça c'est focus maintenant
et on va juste
un peu décalé alors je sais pas pourquoi
la dernière rangée un poil rogner c'est
ça
voilà on est bien mon fable
parfait
on est reparti et donc on a le temps le
début des parties dans la dans le loser
bracket donc si vous avez suivi un peu
comment marche c'est compétition il y a
des joueurs qui ont perdu hier et qui
s'affrontent aujourd'hui s'il repère à
nouveau ils sont éliminés du tournoi et
sinon ils continuent leur route en
espérant tout gagner jusqu'au bout
ça va pas être chose aisé hein non parce
que bon c'est pas bon signe super Joy
premier match globalement tu es pas
favori pour gagner la fin du tournoi
mais bon
on verra un Fab pas favori mais on est
toujours vivant mais toujours vivant
toujours debout
donc on est là donc on attend le début
on a un peu dans expectative
on sera rarement à l'heure ça c'est on
connaît
alors c'est chaud c'est le match de
sauts la forêt je la vois pas connecté
en fait ça le problème après je connais
pas forcément son pseudo
alors ça ne joue pas contre la forêt
d'ailleurs je crois non mais je veux
dire ce serait l'autre match quoi c'est
pour ça que la forêt
[Musique]
contre fedo CIF donc ouais on va on va
suivre les deux
on verra qui commence quand voilà c'est
ça on va se voir qui commence on est
bien on n'est pas en retard on est
parfait
on est bien installé Fab pour pour ce
live quand même un tournoi
extraordinaire avec un plateau
on va le faire rater un tour de France
peut-être on va mettre une pub pour bien
se mettre d'aplomb quoi en fait j'en ai
déjà mis une là ah bravo ah oui voilà je
me sens bien
ça va être vraiment vraiment
spectaculaire aujourd'hui à ne surtout
pas rater et ça attaque fort avec quand
même directement Wesley sceaux un joueur
du top mondial qui est un peu déçu hier
qui a déçu surtout dans cette quatrième
partie qui l'avait en main et puis
il a lâché quoi et c'est Guillet en main
est né
un peu comme une patate chaude non
il a refilé de la patate chaude
ouais
et donc c'est monté des 110 ah non il y
a pas de monter pas du tout c'est il y a
plusieurs divisions mais c'est pendant
la qualification de chaque événement
c'est pas ça devrait pas s'appeler
division d'ailleurs pour éviter les
tournois a ton abonnement assez
peut-être
je peux pas être d'accord avec toi je
pense que
c'est vraiment bien
mais non non ça peut pas
tu peux pas monter ou descendre quoi
rien pour la suite avec toutes les
équipes et on faisait un tournoi au
début pour savoir qui joue en Ligue 1
qui joue en Ligue 2 qui joue en National
et que malgré cette saison l'an prochain
il peut se passer tout et n'importe quoi
peut-être même plus dans aucune des
trois d'ailleurs peut-être tu joues du
pain tu vas être champion
du championnat tu rates ton truc de
calife peut-être tu es en National tu
vois ça veut rien dire
peut-être tu passes même pas la DNCG
était plus pro quoi
ouais c'est quand même pas mal foutu je
trouve
c'est quand même plutôt bien foutu ouais
alors peut-être est-ce que pour se
chauffer on peut regarder un petit peu
la qualité de l'air chez vente forest
peut-être ou chez karwana
c'est pas réglé ces problèmes de chaleur
donc attention attention ça peut lui
faire mal mais parfait
hier c'était juste faire son air là
c'est good quoi
ça va être difficile
il fait vraiment chaud
par contre les commentaires polonais
doit être qualitatif
[Musique]
qui nous intéresse c'est vraiment vent
de Forest mais ouais je suis un peu
inquiet comme tu le dis sur cette
température
quand même assez élevé
je suis toujours pas si c'est connecté
c'est difficile à dire
en tout cas c'est beau
bon on attend les amis
je suis étonné que ça commence
absolument jamais à l'heure
alors ouais mais peut-être qu'il y a pas
un match que j'ai vu
[Musique]
fin de division 3 avoir de division 4
je sais pas trop quoi dire ça
honnêtement
non mais bon si vous avez une
opportunité essayer de voir la fin de
l'état du Tour déjà ça passera le temps
il met aujourd'hui
un petit peu de son
il y a deux gars devant et peut-être
qu'il va à force de pas rouler on va se
faire reprendre par d'autres derrière
l'avance il reste 450 mètres
[Musique]
ça revient derrière
c'est beau 300 mètres encore ça y est
c'est parti le sprinter
c'est beau
c'est terrible
bravo et en plus il fait un beau général
ça commence pareil en tout cas
qui Blitz sinon au pire bon on peut
regarder un peu
FM
[Musique]
ou deux ou trois
je sais pas ce qui se passe en fait
c'est vrai qu'on est pas censé être là
pour aider le title mais bon c'est rien
d'autre à regarder pourquoi pas est-ce
qu'ils ont décalé le truc à cause du
title
[Musique]
je sais pas pourquoi ça a pas commencé
en fait
c'est déjà 12 minutes
non non c'est bien en retard j'ai juste
en retard c'est bon
pas de souci Fab est-ce que tu me
laisses aller faire une petite
respiration
[Musique]
quoi
un peu au title
ou
voilà c'est le title ronde 2 on me dit
pas très bien
ça étoile ronde de bon bah pas
passionnant il a fondé un maître vide
dans bien se passer la 2035 ou 40
secondes il monte sa tour pour peut-être
doubler à noter qu'il aura un pion isolé
du coup c'est une faiblesse latente dans
la position
et on nous dit ça à 17h15 donc on verra
on verra en tout cas on a appuyé pour
suivre les joueurs quand ça démarre donc
ce soit saut ou
ou il trouvait de Saga Je viens de voir
que Big Fish donc de philosophe s'est
connecté donc de ce point de vue là ça
devrait démarrer juste je vois pas avant
de faire face dans la liste des joueurs
mais ça va tarder
alors cette position pour en revenir ici
je pense pas qu'il y a un gros avantage
blanc mais il peut travailler sur
adversaire au corps il attaque le fou
voilà ce pion encrade défense donc pour
l'instant on peut pas enlever le
cavalier pour attaquer parce que la tour
viendra ici maintenant il travaille pour
il s'en va peut-être mettre la tour ici
jouer la finale sans les tours
en cas de prise il pourrait prendre
là-bas ils gardent les tours avec les
mains et décision est très étranges je
trouve parce qu'une tour elle est bien
quoi elle fait des choses alors celle-là
elle a que un rôle passif
sur roi des 6 il va se prendre 4
donc
bon ça a l'air bien pourri quoi on dit
parlons de la SS Fab bah je veux bien il
t'as de chaise mais qu'est-ce que Caton
à dire en fait
tu reprends toujours là pour fille ou
avoir mais je pense que tout tourner
cinq autres biens 3 c'est bien aussi le
fait il menace cahier des trois
fourchette tour C2 tour des deux revient
il va prendre à prendre G6 par échec
prendre ça et avoir une finale de roi
avec un camion de plus complètement
gagnant
donc oui peut-être dans la décalage
d'une minute dans le chat donc ça peut
être évident qu'on a une grande
discussion sur la SSR mais écoute on
verra bien on a bien fini la saison
dernière et cette année cette année mais
on verra ce que ça donne
le
on a déjà recruté un petit peu on va
trouver un attaquant
on va voir on va voir on va bien que
cette année on finisse le mercato avant
le 31 août on serait pas mal de démarrer
la saison au complet et de prendre les
automatismes etc etc
bon ça va une idée pour pour fil rouge
je sais même pas pourquoi ça veut dire
ça joue il y a 2 minutes 30 en face
ça incompréhensible quoi bon d'ailleurs
il a abandonné le gars
il y a y carou qui joue aussi on peut
aller voir un carreau peut-être
car en haut il est là il a les blancs en
train de notre maître fidèle brésilien
celui-là il a encore ça devrait pas trop
résister côté Brésil
un peu comme la partie d'avant qui avait
les contre un fou un peu un peu mauvais
une tour qui peut rentrer en cas de
prise puis on prend les doubler pion il
pourra venir ici taper donc ça a l'air
agréable pour
Rica roux plus que 17 secondes en face
ça a pris mauvais tour G4 qui devrait
juste gagner sur le champ une pièce
bon bah oui c'est fini
donc voilà
bonne question de Mathieu finalement
final
[Musique]
c'est dur à dire parce qu'en fait quand
il y a d'autres pièces il y a fou pion
roi ma belle passe une finale de pion
est fou quoi on appelle ça juste une
finale de fou c'est à des tours et des
pions on a besoin d'une finale de Tours
pareil pour les cavaliers les dames et
quand il y a rien du coup ce qu'on dit
roi pion juste trois espions
mais je pense qu'on peut peut-être même
dire les deux
ou juste finale de pion effectivement
un petit peu
j'aime bien c'est une belle compétition
après je peux pas tout regarder mais
mais j'essaie de suivre un peu les
aujourd'hui j'ai suivi du coin de l'oeil
etc alors c'est parti pour ça on va
regarder ça on avait mis de le truc pour
le suivre mais bon alors c'est une
Sicilienne resolino avec E5 donc un coup
un peu rare je vous fais juste le début
rapidement
peuvent pas vraiment gagner spion un peu
comme dans les Espagnols des changes
donc par contre faut mettre ce fou un
peu bizarre pour tenir le pion
effectivement c'est une concession ce
qui fait quand les gens C3 D4 je lance
un peu mal placé bon cela dit soit je
vais caille C3 c'est un autre setup et
j'avance un peu vite la position on est
comme ça donc si c'est important pour
pas laisser fouger 5 qui correspond
cavalier voir l'échangerait pour prendre
la possession de la case des seins qui
gamme un trou dans la position adverse
et donc les Noirs les Noirs finalement
la structure c'est plus typique des
verbes de 4,5 comme des Espagnols que
que de la Sicilienne mais c'est pas
idiot ce que 5 j'ai essayé de le jouer
une fois là cette année en top
164 il se replace sur cette diagonale
bien placée
D6 et
les Noirs veulent probablement continuer
parfois aussi parce que ils ont pas
encore qu'on leur double les pions
puisque ça ramènerait F7 en E6 qui
donnera un petit un petit contrôle
central donc en général quand les fous
sont comme ça ils se regardent un peu en
chien de faïence personne ne voulant
vraiment échanger
puisque c'est énorme prennent les blancs
reprendrai 2D et ça ouvrir la colonne
sur le pion arrière donc cavalier H2
jouer c'est pas mal
c'est pas le pourquoi parce que il veut
peut-être jouer avec F4 il doit
peut-être jouer avec F4 donc attaquer la
structure adverse et la deuxième option
de tirage 2 c'est de venir en G4 pour
échanger ce cavalier qui est plutôt un
qui avait bien placé parce que on a dit
il couvre cette case des 5 donc une clé
dans cette structure et de deux il peut
prendre des cases pour la dame vers vers
les lois donc il est relativement
utile
pour ces deux choses là
donc allez je vais jouer perso on va
voir ce que fait de CF donc là les
joueurs ont le temps il y a il y a un
quart d'heure chacun alors je vois juste
que
ça un petit peu sauté niveau
exactement écoute j'essaie de remettre
hop là bah écoute ça va à peu près je
pense que Kiabi fera mieux après mais au
moins on va l'échiquier de notre côté
peut-être faire un dernier truc c'est ça
hop
voilà je dirais Kiev ça a sauté et que
mais on s'en sort on peut aller chiquer
lequel est venu donc en G4 comme on a
dit pour
après changer celui-là
pour échanger celui-là et donc
avoir ensuite peut-être que ça c'est le
cas donc et B4 pas mal hein de la part
des Noirs c'est un joli coup quand les
blancs font à 4 ça fait bien passer de
casse B4 non le cavaler ici contrôle
bien cette case des 5 et aussi garde un
œil sur le pion C2 donc la dame D1 n'a
plus toute sa liberté de mouvement
donc dessus maintenant avec les Noirs la
question c'est ce qu'ils prennent ou pas
donc il a pris sa double lépion d'un
match quatre attaque le pion donc je
m'attends peut-être à F3 pour pour le
défendre a priori
mais ça va je pense que les Blancs ne
craignent rien malgré une structure pion
un peu étrange on va dire mais même ces
pions G comme ça doublé ça peut donner
un potentiel au blanc le long de la
colonnage un jour alors faudrait pouvoir
décaler le roi passer la tour mais c'est
possible qu'à un moment puisse jouer que
j'ai 5
ultérieurement donc F3 jouer ça défend
plutôt logique faut aussi s'en phase de
l'autre
et maintenant à Westland jouer alors
peut-être un petit coup de développement
le long de cette diagonale avec le fou
pour faire participer toutes ces pièces
au jeu et puis aussi ce fou une fois que
ce sera des deux ou en E3 il pourrait un
peu chasser cette dame H4 qui bon qui
menace rien pour l'instant mais qui est
un peu pénible quoi c'est un peu une
épée de damoclas au-dessus de la tête je
préfère qu'elles sont des 8 là-bas dans
son camp que là à tricoter quoi
donc
ouais un petit changement de règles donc
par rapport à hier c'est que aujourd'hui
dans les parties comme ça là dans dans
le bracket des loosers c'est des matchs
en deux parties donc contrairement aux
autres il y en a quatre c'est-à-dire
qu'une défaite fait vraiment mal c'est
must win immédiatement dans la seconde
et donc tout va plus vite mais bon
ils ont perdu une fois
ne peut pas non plus faire des journées
de 15 heures de tournoi quoi donc et B5
choisi par Wesley qui attaque ce fou
bon donc il peut soit l'enlever sur le
défendre ce qu'il a fait et donc je sais
pas si compte continuer par C3 pour
chasser ce qui a une B4 ou c'est juste
une là pour venir là et qu'il attend que
les Noirs peut-être le chasse pour
ressortir ou que il reviendra mais l'un
dans l'autre s'il faut B8 revient c'est
7 on n'aura pas perdu de temps et on
aura provoqué à 6 pas que ce soit une
faiblesse mais c'est peut-être pas le
coup le plus utile de la position donc
quelque part pour gagner un temps
parce qu'en B8 quand même il est
pas bien dans le sens où il bloque la
tour c'est-à-dire que la tour sera
ailleurs pourquoi pas le mettre en B8
mais là en fait ça simple présence en B8
fait que la tour à 8 ne participe au jeu
et les Noirs j'aurais bien aimé avoir la
tour quelque part sur une de ces trois
cases
donc je sais pas si Wesley compte voilà
faire ces trois ou juste se développer
et attendre à 6 probablement que les
deux coups doivent être jouable
j'imagine
en tout cas ça réfléchit mais voilà
c'était parti semi-rapie hein donc ça
c'est quand même le temps un quart
d'heure plus 3 secondes par coup c'est
c'est assez long pour faire des parties
descentes et justement prendre le temps
de la réflexion quand
il faut alors ça donne quoi Magnus
carwana alors ça sera plus tard malus
contre karwana c'est-à-dire qu'il va
d'abord y avoir le match des perdants
ici donc les joueurs qui ont perdu leur
match hier donc il y a à la fois
celui-là entre Wesley Sow et Vladimir
fait de Saif et en même temps il y a
vente forest un Jordan qui joue contre
historique saga et une fois que c'est
dommage seront terminés alors on aura
les vainqueurs d'hier qui feront leur
entrée en lice et donc c'est les
cultures c'est les demi-finales des
vainqueurs donc ce sera le match entre
Carlson et kerwana donc on suivra bien
sûr en priorité mais il y aura aussi
également un autre match assez alléchant
entre les vannes à rognan et
le petit abdosa t'aura
c'est pas mal aussi sur le papier voilà
Magnus façon on aime toujours voir ça
mais les Van a bossa torov c'est cool
aussi donc là dans switchera de temps en
temps et on
vous fera de toute façon un pointage
score de ce qui se passe à côté
bon tu vois ça réfléchit toujours chez
Wesley
donc je sais pas en fait pourquoi autant
de réflexion ici c'est peut-être qu'il
doit penser que la position des sites
pas mal de réflexion à ce moment là et
d'être précis
donc
à voir niveau qualité de l'air donc
toujours cette technologie ring on peut
voir donc chez Jordan une belle qualité
d'herbe mais 28 degrés 28 degrés un peu
chaud un peu chaud il a pas pu changer
par rapport à hier ou déjà il faisait 27
on voit le petit cadran rouge ici
chez caroanna c'est un peu pareil il
était de l'air très bonne
mais 27 degrés donc il va être dans les
mêmes conditions un petit peu que Jordan
hier pour monter Magnus et c'est dommage
qu'on n'est pas les boîtiers chez les
autres joueurs mais ça nous donne un
petit gadget pour poursuivre tout ça
et vérifier que les joueurs soit donc
très bonne condition pour pour bien
cliquer alors ces trois finalement le
coût choisi par Wesley donc voilà
c'était la raison aussi pour laquelle il
a quitté la case avec le cavier ça
libère la case et donc le pion peut
venir chasser ce cavalier qui a priori
va être retiré en C6 alors peut-être que
l'autre option que fait dossiere ne joue
pas tempo c'est qui calcule le coût des
5 qui est un coup intermédiaire en se
disant bon bah si les blancs prennent je
reprends mon tour le français 4 et si
les blancs venaient à prendre ici je
retirerai le cavalier au centre en
dessin
point peut-être un coup comme E4 alors à
calculer je sais pas trop ce que ça
donne si c'est pas genre trop hâtif
aussi mais possible quand on avait dit
c'est dommage 4 c'est un peu une épée de
Damoclès au dessus de la tête et si ces
deux pions venaient à disparaître on
voit que le fou et la dame pour être
allé de concert pour la case H2 et mater
le roi blanc donc des cinq est joué
effectivement en cas de prise je
m'attends donc à cavalier prend mais ce
que je vous disais c'est que peut-être
ce coup est jouable
et là faut pas craquer avec les Blancs
c'est à dire faut sûrement boucher la
déguns du Fou d'une manière ou d'une
autre je pense avec des six parce que si
jamais on fait les idiots et qu'on prend
le cavalier là il y a Matt avec fois H2
voilà fou G3 important bloque la case de
fuite du roi et le mat de la dame en H2
donc D5
des 5 bien joué et Wesley s'en fout
voilà donc il est pas parti il a pas
pris ce qui pourrait libérer ce fou il a
juste reculer
[Musique]
bon c'est vrai que c'est pas mal c'est
un coup que j'ai même pas regardé de
prime abord et c'est plutôt bien joué
puisqu'en fait on garde ce cavalier si
il bouge on pourra peut-être encaisser
le pion toujours regarder les quatre
bien sûr mais pourquoi pas
et
donc elle fait dos de jouer
les noces de jouets
ouais
il peut se passer plein de coups
comme caille prend des trois peut-être
jouable avec l'idée qu'il prend à me
prendre de faire ses quatre et de
regagner le fouet 3 en échange donc
c'est chaud en fait c'est chaud c'est
chaud on verra ce qui va jouer en tout
cas il a explication cette position où
les choses se compliquent après un début
une tournure un peu plus positionnelle
où ça joue un peu les cases notamment
cette case D5 etc là on est rentré dans
le vif du sujet avec un peu des pièces
partout mais peut-être que Wesley va se
mordre les doigts dans la laisser cette
dame là bas sans être allée la chasser
on va voir comment ça tourne ces quatre
jouets immédiatement donc ces quatre
coups pareil intermédiaires donc il y
avait toujours attaqué mais on
contre-attaque le fou et on enlève un
des attaquants de dessin car dessus
les blancs peuvent peut-être prendre ici
peuvent être prendre là aussi peut-être
faire ce prendre toujours d'abord mais
il faut toujours compter sur ce coup de
4 comme on a dit qu'ils auraient sortir
ce foot satanière après les échanges
avec la dame il travaille sur H2 on a vu
un schéma note avec foi de Fougères
donc voilà on va essayer de trouver
comment défendre
sinon je vois qu'on me demande si j'ai
déjà joué le toit sur Loire alors ça
fait longtemps mais j'y allais
fréquemment quand j'étais petit c'est un
gros tournoi au Rex sur Loire c'était un
rapide et sur le samedi sur le dimanche
il y avait vraiment des beaux joueurs
maintenant je sais que c'est plus que le
dimanche et je crois que je l'ai rejouer
je sais pas peut-être 4 5 6 ans j'arrive
plus trop à compter les années mais je
la rejoins il y a pas si longtemps
si encore on peut dire que ça soit il y
a pas si longtemps cinq ans mais mais
non j'ai déjà fait
plusieurs fois voilà
et donc on arrive sur l'or pour ceux qui
connaissent pas c'est un petit patelin
je crois que c'est en Haute-Loire mais
c'est pas très loin de Saint-Étienne
donc un peu dans ma région
c'était un beau un beau tournant
donc cela un peu dans le dur après ce
que c'est 4 et il le bouffe donc les
marrons reprendre il prend le cavalier
mais il va a priori prendre le fou
alors non il faut encore un coup
intermédiaire un festival de coin
intermédiaires et il attaque du coup le
cavalier et le fou donc on ne pourra pas
sauver les deux à la fois
alors pourquoi elle le fait maintenant
je sais pas exactement mais sûrement
parce que il faut à 7 en fait bêtement
c'est lequel il s'en va donc c'est pas
bêtement en fait c'est assez fin de sa
part
pour un nouveau mettre le roi dans la
zone mat donc joli à 6 avec le fou qui
vient par ici c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on va forcément souvent un fou qui
suit ce trajet pour aller attaquer là le
roi mais je lis souplesse la part des
noirs et dextérité des pièces ça me
rappelle une idée une fois une partie de
casse par œuf contre piquette dans une
Indienne qui avait envoyé la dame là-bas
clown tu as fini avec un cavalier H1
une vieille partie enfin des années 80
mais un peu de genre de truc donc il a
pris en B5 il y a eu fou 3 ouais bon bah
il se développe et il couvre la case à 7
mais en tout cas clairement c'est plutôt
avantage noir cette position parce que
des pièces plus actives une plutôt
meilleure structure
mais il y a rien de faire il y a rien de
faire il est quand même arrivé à
colmater après ce que j'aime pas à côté
blanc évidemment c'est se foutez d'eux
qui est qui aime bien pourri il est
bloqué par ses propres options de ce
côté de l'échiquier et ce pion C4 le
restreint ici donc
en quoi c'est un mauvais fou mais après
après c'est pas foutu non plus hein
c'est juste une position plutôt
difficile à jouer mais il faudra la
tenir
dame à jouer donc
qui a fait son retour peut-être
ça me fait mal au cœur de rater sa femme
tu pourras m'aider un peu j'ai recentré
les chiquets mais il est un peu sauté
[Musique]
enfin
je sais pas il y avait pas la première
rangée des blancs
je sais pas
en fait quand on a mis suivre Wesley ça
suffit pas je me suis rendu compte je
suis allé cliquer pour le voir et donc
ça a sauté donc bon on est quand même
arrivé à voir la partie mais tu vois
c'était pas le gris tu es pas très gris
quoi j'ai bien vu
c'est bon mais le chat est bien là est
bien là mais le chat souffre depuis
cette quatrième partie hier
[Musique]
il a du mal ici un peu coupé les griffes
quand il
il pose la pâte quoi il est sympa
bon toujours est-il que depuis que tu es
là ça a l'air d'être équilibré
de la griffe au chat peut-être de la
griffe
à la Volverine
il y a du gravier quoi
un petit poucet 7 donc bon libère la
tour le long de la 8e rangée
éventuellement
alors il y a que deux parties on nous a
rappelé si tu fais bien de bien le
spécifier parce que c'est important
donc c'est aller-retour
et alors ma gueule après si jamais avec
les 8 minutes 12 hier par Wesley portant
ce qui fera pareil parce que il a pas
fait long feu la partie dans les 3
minutes
tu es intéressé en tout cas cette partie
Fab
elle a été intéressante là bon tout d'un
coup l'impression
très belle partie en tout cas il est
beau hein son chat Wesley j'adore
comme ça
[Musique]
en tout cas c'est intéressant un Fab
comme partie passionnant le tour qui vit
en C1 ta question C4 va t-il le gagner
ne va-t-il pas le gagner c'est la
question là qu'on est en train de se
poser à Fabien à 17h34
ce qui peut réussir à faire foudre
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est une bonne idée ou pas
les noirs peuvent peut-être le prendre
plein de choses possible
intéressant en tout cas
passionnant Fab cette partie ce pion C4
un petit peu esseulé peut-être en danger
c'est vrai bien arrivé à faire B5 mais
bon
malheureusement il y a un fond à 4
donc il fait bien le spécifier c'est pas
le fond à 4 c'est vrai que B5 sur un
bout ou alors s'il était protégé voilà
ça crée le fou en baby ça serait bien ça
et le fou et protéger le pion
one stone two Burns dans l'autre sens ce
serait magnifique femme
pour sa partie on voit sa qualité d'air
pas au niveau de la température il y a
une inquiétude quand même chez Fabiano à
moins que le capteur soit proche de
l'ordinateur avec l'ordi chauffe avec le
tour centrale et
ça fausse
très bien qu'on est aussi la température
ressentie
ouais ça c'est vrai que ce serait bien
température ressenti parce que par
exemple là nous on a vraiment chaud
on su quoi mais j'ai pas de thermomètre
je suis à quel température il fait
mais il fait chaud c'est sûr
je vais ouvrir la porte quoi
bon en tout cas voilà l'espace plus
grand-chose
l'initiative adverse on a attention
quand même un petit tourment à 3 qui
traîne en reprend fou G5 enfilade donc
c'est un peu un petit piégeot ce qui
traîne
après bon d'être en mesure de la vitesse
mais bon ah non très très malin de la
part de
100% d'humidité c'est que tu es dans
l'eau ou pas et je sais pas est-ce qu'il
y a des spécialistes météo dans le chat
qui pourrait nous déclarer là-dessus
[Musique]
les joueurs sont joue pour ça quoi et
pour ce magnifique trophée alors le site
c'est championne il y a un point io je
sais pas si on a le lien dans le chat si
on a modérateur qui a le lien exact pour
faire quoi pour pouvoir retrouver les
trophées importants
en tout cas ils sont sur un site
d'accord et donc ils auront ce
magnifique trophée avec le cerveau dans
la dans la course un peu comme la tête
winner donc ils ont probablement son
heure non à poser qui vont enlever
winner et mettre je suppose ouais et
quand même le petit avion là qui passe
se dire championne
[Musique]
je me fais un peu penser au nuage des
Simpson quelque part c'est
magnifique trophée qui va être gagné
donc
par le vainqueur du tournoi
ça motive ça motive quand tu gagnes ça
donc ça joue pas que pour l'argent mais
aussi pour ce pour ce trophée
surtout surtout
le max d'eau que peut retenir l'air donc
tu es pas dans l'eau à 100% d'humidité
c'est juste que l'air ne peut pas être
plus humide
alors plus d'eau dans l'air et sinon
c'est pas possible en fait juste
plus d'eau que ça en fait
si dans l'eau quoi
47 % de l'humidité il y a de l'eau
jusqu'au genou quoi
en tout cas les Noirs qu'on solidifier
le pion C4 avec ce coup B5 les blancs
sont pas pris l'enfilade et donc il se
passe plus grand chose
mais là il ne peut il ne peut plus rien
se passer non
de joueurs qui sont gratifiés d'une très
très belle performance dans cette partie
Fabien et c'est que le loser bracket
j'ai envie de dire ça après que le match
carwana
déjà on a une quelque part une première
partie déjà
extraordinaire
n'ayons pas peur des mots
intéressants
pour Wesley 1 c'est peut-être pour ça
que ça joue encore
la défaillance de la connexion du joueur
américain peut-être ouais c'est possible
en tout cas ce serait malin de sa part
ce serait très très bien joué ah mais
c'est vrai que c'est des paramètres
qui sont de 41 grâce à son adversaire
qui pouvait pas faire promotion cavalier
il est en auto Queen il savait pas
modifié il était là il a buggé il est
tombé
et là aujourd'hui peut-être avec cette
connexion pas au top peut-être du aux
grosses chaleurs je sais pas
voilà peut-être qu'à en haut cela va
plus pouvoir clique
intéressante en tout cas cette fin de
partie qui peut se jouer à la connexion
à West qui récupère la connexion
quand même F5 hein ferme vraiment la
partie mais bon
superbe partie en tout cas entre les
deux hommes une passe d'armes
une passe d'armes
voilà il réfléchit mais difficile de
savoir quoi quand même il prend bah
prendre à pousser ou à rien faire
tout allait sûrement
peut-être se faire on prend et
j'ai 5 et G4 et
on va voir
j'ai 5 et 4 ça bloque quand même pas mal
hein
il y a plus de passage nulle part
à moins que
qui est absolument anecdotique et
il peut attendre et bouger son coup de
caisse blanche maintenant de gauche à
droite
faire des petits va-et-vient
belle partie en tout cas très très belle
partie
très belle finale très très bien joué il
faut quand même réussir encore à faire
nul côté blanc ici
c'est trop apprécis
ne pas être tenter de prendre ce fou
ne pas être tenté de prendre le fou
c'est tout ce qu'il faut pour tenir la
nul maintenant en attendant
une erreur de Wesley ce mano Amano
peut-être
une connexion défaillante qui peut faire
la différence
spectacle est en tout cas à son comble
là ce premier match
en tout cas
qui réfléchit quand même
il a raison il y a peut-être encore des
choses à faire dans cette position
il se passe il se passe plus rien et ça
y est l'annuler
entre les deux hommes mais quelle partie
Fabien quelle partie et nous nous ont
offert
dans la prochaine on verra
et alors dans l'autre partie de ce 12 AR
bracket entre mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que ça
mais alors il joue dans quoi en 15 + 3
c'est ça
[Musique]
il y a un pion de plus pour les blancs
mais ils sont en train de se faire
attaquer c'est sûrement une est indienne
c'est parti
il y a kg 4 qui peut gagner une qualité
qui gagne
du coup
avec toi la pression sur H3 si jamais la
touref pouvait arriver en
f7h7 ou F5 H5 bon ça rajoutera du poids
à cette attaque
ça rajouterais du poids
c'est quand même une qualité de plus
et l'attaque exactement
donc il a pris en bus ici il va prendre
ces choses faites c'est dur avec 50
secondes positions même avec plus simple
c'est tout le temps dur mais là
pour défendre ça
qu'il a raté
il tente un cloche latéral
la tour s'en va toujours pas prendre le
fou puisque Adam prend
et sur cette menace la tente
qu'il a peut-être vu maintenant
et Tori Zaga qui va probablement
s'incliner là si fait froid c'est
terminé
après le coup conservateur F5 va
sûrement mais je crois c'est le bon coup
dans la position très long cou le
meilleur coup
H5 d'un projet de maths
il va sûrement le faire
surtout si il prend le temps de la
réflexion
joue vite fait F5 le coup fainéant si tu
réfléchis C'est que c'est que tu
cherches mieux et que tu vas trouver
une partie encore d'un très haut niveau
cette fin de partie ouais je sais pas le
début je pense c'était indienne
et
toujours dangereux que
le danger est présent bien évidemment
on travaille ce qui prend son temps
avant de venir conclure à la volée
déposer la balle
côté opposé
bien mettre le
pied
pour bien faire le passage passé le
corps et non
il peut encore toucher la balle qui est
en train de courir
une balle facile allez il faut faire le
point là il va falloir appuyer cette
deuxième volet
je veux faire le point en deux temps
ça peut marcher aussi il faut le faire
qui court sur la balle qui a réussi à
remettre mais de justesse là ça reste
une balle quand même à mi-court assez
facile
il va falloir distribuer le jeu Fabien
avec le coup droit
quand même il est bien il a tous les
angles ouverts
un pion dans cette histoire
tu rage 4 bon en fait tu fais le plan
simple de pilonner la colonnage
c'est pas encore terminé
il réussit pas à mettre le coup de grâce
il veut prendre du foin H3 donc il
défend son pion G6
et la séduire un pourritorise à gaz
juste de jouer un coup
il va falloir qu'il revienne à grande
enjamber c'est ce qui tente de faire
mais le pion qui tombe
le fou qui le suit il réussit encore à
défendre pour le moment
solide le joueur espagnol
il reste dans l'échange il couvre bien
son cours quand même
loin de sa ligne de fonds
espagnols mais les pièces de ventes qui
convergent
qui arrive de toute part il va falloir
s'incliner là maintenant côté côté
espagnol il y a le fouet 5 qui attaqué
il y a tout qui attaqué il tombe
malheureusement ça va faire un point
pour pour vendre forest ses amis on va
prendre une petite respiration parce que
ça va vite vite repartir après côté côté
West les sourd on se retrouve très vite
pour voir
si wesh les sauts réussis à tenir avec
moi
avec les pièces noires réussir à réagir
ou si on sera on sera à la fin de ces
espoirs dans ce tournoi on se retrouve
très très vite avec une petite publicité
pour l'excellent système à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les amis on a vraiment un petit bug pour
le suivi il est parti se lancent pas
alors on rate pas grand chose évidemment
mais c'est un peu dommage surtout que
voilà on est quand même sur sur de
l'exceptionnel Fab
en tout cas
cette magnifique ouverture
on va revenir dessus c'est une sorte de
catalane sans D4
que voici
bon intéressantes pas très risqué mais
vous pouvez y avoir une petite pression
à gérer côté noir malgré tout
grâce à ce fou G2 donc il rayonne le
long de la grande diagonale etc donc
très jouable pour pour les blancs
ça nous promet une partie passionnante
Fab ouais
A4 ou pas A4
ou s'il laisse les faire B5 pour faire à
4 ensuite moi je sais pas on va voir
mais globalement on va dire aller chez
My idéal pour les Noirs serait de faire
baisser 5 et faut baisserte et tout va
bien parce que tu
contrecarres se fout dans la grande
diagonale etc
et voilà donc là il fait fou F4
il se développe tout en parlant la
menace
[Musique]
des 6
mesdames reprend voilà donc bon ensuite
prolon un petit rock à venir
on va voir Fabien on va laisser la
partie avancée tranquillement
je CF au service pour pour cette
deuxième partie on sait un qui est début
de partie sont importants Fabien
ah bah ouais ça donne le la pour la
suite
à partir de la partie
et
les deux vraiment magnifique petit rock
peut-être il faut lui aussi ok ce qui
serait un joli coup
normal tranquille et après comme
mais rock c'est quand même ultra naturel
ce serait un coup extrêmement logique
Fabien joli coup qui vient d'être joué
petit rock ça joue vraiment fort
[Musique]
peut-être un coup de pion B voilà
est-ce qu'il y a cavalier 5 qui peut
marcher qui sera un joli coup aussi qui
jouerait
sur le ce serait joli
attention faut toujours compter dessus
quand on touche au pion en B on ouvre
encore plus le fouger 2 qui par des
combinaisons sur la tour à 8 donc
n'importe quel cavalier peut sauter à
droite à gauche après qu'il y avait eu 5
bon bah soit il fera quel dessin pour
bloquer soit il bougera sa tour un plan
à 7 ou je sais pas faut voir
très joli parti pour le moment
j'espère que vous vous délectez de ces
matchs
après c'est vrai que que tu auras 7
peut-être il y a un souci il est venu
ici plutôt
tu auras ça je vais attendre un souci
c'est qu'on peut faire qui est ici ce
qui est C4 ok c'est 4 d'abord les jardin
de C7 qui est ici c'est la tour un peu
prise au piège ça va retourner sur une
case blanche c'est vraiment très Caliot
7 échec et on pourrait encaisser la
qualité
alors je disais que c'est 4 d'abord
quand
c'est un peu con sur la dame prend des
quatre
c'est intéressant ce coup cahier des
cartes quand même c'est un joli coup
hein ça met une pièce en prise mais pour
remanger le la tour derrière c'est du
très très haut niveau là qu'on est en
train de voir
comment comment on esquive tout ça
est-ce que tu penses que OSC est quand
même peut être sous pression il peut se
faire éliminer ce soir de ce champion de
chaise tours est-ce que tu penses ça lui
rajoute un stress une pression quand
même c'est une compétition qui qui doit
lui tenir à cœur
après il est pas bien parti dans le
temps à toute façon
ça lui pourront nez ça lui prend on est
mais oui bien sûr c'est toujours
stressant pour être
très éliminé un tournoi bon ils font ce
qu'ils peuvent quand même pour être
qu'on soit bien sûr et là bon ce serait
bien sûr que ce soit éliminé donc
c'est toujours mal au cœur ça fait qu'en
plus tu peux pas gagner le trophée donc
coup dur quoi
donc ça peut expliquer aussi un peu ça
ça m'efforme qui pourrait être expliqué
par la pression
qui subit
il veut vraiment pas faire d'erreur
il a plus qu'une vie dans ce tournoi
précis gagne tous les matchs il le
gagnera ce tournant il fait cavalier des
cinq donc la seule logique qui bloque le
fouger 2 donc c'est une manière dont de
parer la menace sur la tour à 8 sans
avoir à y toucher
et sa place un joli cavalier au centre
donc attaque la dame Rome encore en
prise le truc c'est que si on prend ce
cavalier bien sûr les blancs sur le
cahier des cinq alors après est-ce que
c'est grave ça c'est une autre histoire
peut-être que les Nord peuvent tout à
fait accepter d'entrer là dedans
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il choisit de
faire il a pris dame prend des cinq bon
dame prend obligé je vous prends et
Tours je sais pas à 7 B8 un des deux des
jolis coups pour le moment
donc les Blancs ont une structure pure
un peu meilleur mais franchement c'est 4
pions à l'ail droit là ils sont pas
faibles je pense que c'est ça va pour
les Noirs en fait
il n'y a pas du tout perdu dans la
demeure
donc peut-être peut-être qu'on dira une
nouvelle nul et éventuellement un nouvel
armée
vraiment bien pour le spectacle
ce soir parce que peut-être ensuite on
aura les autres matchs qui démarreraient
on ne sait pas trop à quelle heure on
suivra ça du point de l'oeil et puis et
puis c'est match il peut déjà donc
quatre parties mais en cas de deux qui a
notre Armageddon le temps des enchères
tout ça peut-être un autre compagnie
jusqu'à bien 23h ce soir
qui serait ce serait quand même une
soirée longue et palpitante
en termes de jeux et d'enjeux
en espérant que
l'enjeu ne prenne pas le pas sur le jeu
est important
dans ce match rappelle une qualification
en jeu pour les demi-finales du loser
bracket de ce tournoi avec un
gros gros price poule un magnifique
trophée
tournoi d'été un peu l'équivalent du
Wimbledon souvent qui a lieu du Tour de
France
mais côté échec Fabien
beaucoup G5 qui est parti une jolie
plus un G6 qui consolide tout et c'est
aussi leur un petit peu s'activer vers
GSM
mais le coup est quelque part d'autant
plus jolie Fabien car surprenant
parfois une
petit coup comme ça qui peut peut-être
paraître mauvais mais ça peut être un
peu comme une balle net au tennis ça
peut attendre du bon côté aussi un petit
coup de réussite
[Musique]
surtout si c'est sur balle de break
et là c'est une balle de break Fabien
forcément même une balle de match
exactement
selon que
la balle prenne le bon ou le mauvais
côté du filet j'en veux une vie ça peut
changer beaucoup de choses
surtout si ça s'enchaîne avec de belles
premières balles de service
pour ces trois à jouer
et on est peut-être là en train de vivre
un peu ce moment
après pour ces trois coups un peu
multifonction qui permet de doubler les
tours et puis ensuite peut-être de faire
à 3 B4 pour peut-être ouvrir cette
colonne C et avoir la prédominance
dessus avec les deux tours et puis
peut-être j'adore ces trois peut aussi
un moment se décaler vers à trois vers
B3 alors pour le moment évidemment on
t'en met trois c'est complètement contré
par par B5 mais qui sait peut-être plus
tard et les cinq qui attaquent qui
attaquent cette tour
eh ben soit il va donner son fou il va
reculer
je pense qu'il va se séparer de son fou
cette finale
qui peut être une finale long courrier
long cours je sais pas enfin
final très intéressantes en tout cas en
train d'être joué Fabien
chef qui réfléchit en tout cas ils
attendaient pas à ce coup-ci
le foie repris et F4 il vient fixer la
structure et ce pion F5 faiblard qui va
rester là plus défendu peut-être dans la
regretter ce pion ce pion G5 finalement
que la balle retournera du mauvais côté
du filet on verra
avec un purge ici ça serait beaucoup
plus solide il serait jamais une
faiblesse là comme ça bon bah à un
moment qui avait lieu trois ça peut
arriver t'attaquer le pion un petit tour
à F1 frangin
[Musique]
attention quand même quoi
qui pourrait être pénible tout à fait
une finale de tour
final de double tour
ne finale de Coupe du monde alors
faudrait quand même pas exagérer Franck
Aria peut-être pas final de coupe du
monde mais quart de finale
un petit peu un petit peu exagéré c'est
un peu comme le France Angleterre de
la dernière Coupe du monde
très la mission F4
on prend
donc il va reprendre on va prendre ses
quatre je pense ouais
plus tard mais bon les blancs à tout
moment peuvent s'en aller faire quel
lieu trois notamment s'ils ont envie
pour essayer de défendre tout ce beau
monde
bref 6
en tout cas c'est ça qui est beau ici
avec ce format rapide c'est qu'on avait
on a l'habitude dans les parties longues
de ces journées qui durent 5-6 heures
mais on voit qu'une partie et là on a
peut-être l'occasion que ça dure 5-6
heures mais d'en voir peut-être 7 voire
même 8
ça ce serait vraiment extraordinaire là
c'est que la deuxième partie de la
journée
mais il y a encore peut-être
si chef-d'œuvre et demi à venir
n'ayons pas peur des mots
après je trouve ça formant qui serait
pas mal dans des interclubs de genre
plus amateurs
peut-être pas d'en faire 8 et faire deux
ou aller 3 ou 4 rapide dans l'après-midi
c'est peut-être mieux que de taper le
déplacement pour l'interclub et te faire
une partie longue
peut-être très longue peut-être très
courtes peut-être même que ton
anniversaire fait forfait n'est pas venu
c'est tout à fait vrai
après évidemment le défaut
ça ne compterait pas pour le classement
et l'autre partie longue
et ce serait bien dommage mais du coup
pourquoi jouer quoi
donc les noirs
est plutôt pour les blancs étant donné
que les Noirs pourraient jouer vite pour
lutter mais attention et cahier cette
fourchette
donc en fait ce tour des 8 elle est
plutôt paralysée par ici à défendre
cette case et voilà donc il y a pas trop
de coups à jouer pour l'instant elle est
blanc pourraient pour en profiter
peut-être pour redescendre la tour C3
verset 1 mettre l'autre tout ranger 5 et
débarquer le nom de la colonne g attaqué
un peu les pions là-bas alors réussi ça
a été joué justement peut-être pour
libérer cette tour D8 qui pourrait
maintenant venir en G8 mais bon laisse
la case G7 quand même vacante
pour la tour qui pourrait descendre
le long de la septième rangée alors
après faut regarder s'ils sont tombés ça
tu veux pas jouer un coup comme toi j'ai
8 peut-être il laisse H7 mais qui veut
faire tourger deux et s'active à son
tour
intéressant en tout cas très intéressant
Fabien ma vision voilà c'est important
pour la suite
de ce match et de cette compétition
parce que le perdant serait éliminé
malheureusement
tourne cette
le coup le coup francif et si chasse le
cavalier des fonds C4
bon alors il reste le pion h quand même
à sauver on a sauvé le pion F c'est déjà
un sur les deux
on sauve le deuxième mais bon ce pion F6
c'est un peu moins bien placé quand même
alors pourquoi ça
je sais pas je le trouve moins moins
harmonieux
bloc un peu la case pour le roi
peut-être
difficile en tout cas
qui s'amuse pas qui est plutôt du
mauvais côté de la nul on va dire mais
pour l'instant il y a encore rien de
trop grave pour lui mais c'est pas une
partie en Balante même si bon elle est
habitude c'est parti il faut un peu
défendre ou tu es visuellement un peu
moins bien mais il arrive à être précis
j'en parle pas le terme pas en ballant
parce que la partie en soi elle est en
Balante côté côté public côté
côté phéhé c'est plutôt une partie
difficile à jouer pour les Noirs mais
j'aime pas trop ce terme de pas en
ballon que tu as que tu as employé mes
excuses
je pense qu'il faut être plus plus
précis dans le dans les adjectifs
employés
mais elle revient se replacer direction
G1
on peut toujours pas vraiment prendre à
deux puisque a priori il y aura torrent
attaque ce fou qui doit avoir répartir
et on récupérerait le pion à 6
ce sera plutôt bon échange pour les
blancs
donc les noirs
[Musique]
qui était un peu pris ça aurait pu
préparer un coup comme
B400 B4
ça réfléchit en tout cas
[Musique]
spectacle est au rendez-vous on aurait
pu être inquiet que le que l'enjeu
c'est pas le cas
il y a pas d'erreur
il y a pas d'erreur ça joue précis de
part et d'autre
niveau de jeu qui atteint des sommets
dans ce match
tour G6 un joli coup qui ne lâche pas la
colonne vertes et c'est les blancs
venaient à prendre cette tour elle en
reprend le H reformerait une belle
structure de pions donc notre rend pas
mieux étant impressionné par le dernier
coup d'énorme les blancs font pareil ils
copient stratégie du miroir avec toi
stratégie qui peut s'avérer gagnante
donc ça c'est la seconde partie avec
cette cadence là et quoi qu'il se passe
ce sera la dernière après on aura
peut-être un Armageddon c'est des matchs
en deux parties de ce côté du bracket
meilleur du deuxième le bracket des
loosers
c'est vrai que j'avais trouvé ça un peu
un petit peu dommage tu vois je suis où
il me le donne de très loin Fabien
évidemment pas possible de suivre au
milieu de tous ces tournois mais j'étais
un peu un peu déçu de voir que les
joueurs une fois qu'ils ont perdu un
match ils sont directement éliminés
qui reviennent et qui puisse avoir une
deuxième chance à évite les mauvaises
surprises tu es en début de tournoi pas
vraiment en forme là on voit un westso
aujourd'hui top mondial qui a du coup
une deuxième chance une deuxième
cartouche
imagine par exemple
un Roland Garros mon Rafa eu beaucoup de
chance de réussir à toujours gagner mais
t'es jamais à l'abri de perdre un match
et donc cette ligne à l'époque
et avoir un Roland-Garros avec deux vies
Oreo aurait peut-être permis d'avoir
moins de moins de surprises exactement
la fête du tennis c'est un petit peu la
même chose avec avec Wimbledon
et jamais vraiment sûr que le que le
meilleur gagne parce que ils ont
tu peux avoir ce jour où tu passes à
côté finalement et pas avoir cette
deuxième chance qui te permet de rester
en vie quand même pas mal de réussite je
trouve ça quand même souvent été les
numéros mondiaux qui gagnait
depuis 2003 que Federer Nadal meurt Joko
qui ont gagné mais je suis pas je suis
pas bon est-ce que c'était vraiment les
meilleurs je suis pas sûr que le BIC le
Big fort a gagné autant de Grand Chelem
s'il y avait ces double chance
finalement c'est vrai qu'il passe
rarement à côté de leur match mais
peut-être que les autres voilà en
quelques jours un peu plus à vide mais
aurait pu avec un bon niveau de jeu
finalement revenir via le looser bracket
et finalement se débarrasser que ce soit
de Roger Federer à Wimbledon ou de
Raphaël Nadal à Roland-Garros ou encore
de
[Musique]
de Djokovic
était finalement peut-être
pas tant au dessus mais juste plus
régulier finalement que les autres puis
au final peut-être là de savoir tu peux
avoir deux chances tu peux aussi
peut-être taper tous tes coups à fond
les lignes dans un bon jour ça passe ça
passe pas la deuxième chance tu peux
recommencer
l'esprit plus libre et
avoir une
une puissance
plus importante dans tes coups
non en plus tu serais pas si fatiguée
parce que dans le dans le loser bracket
tu ferais des matchs
gagnants donc c'est à plus vite
en pleine forme pour la finale quoi
complètement
on va peut-être même voir là une
stratégie en fait de perdre auto
serait redoutable on se forme
serait déjà à mon avis à 4 ou 5 grands
Chelem
au minimum
ça avance côté noir allez le dame ils
vont pas vraiment envie de prendre
celui-là
qui viendrait le refaire un pion passé à
qui serait redoutable dans cette
position donc vaut mieux pas toucher
côté blanc
en tout cas qui a bien rétabli la
position
il a fait à 4 4 ça fait quand même une
cible sur casse blanche mais en même
temps c'est vrai que ce fou aussi a du
mal à quitter sa position puisque s'il
s'en allait ça paraît le pion F5 donc il
faudrait réfléchir au moins deux fois
en tout cas le temps qui se fait rare
moins de 30 maintenant
ce tournoi
c'est pour ça
je suis pas très bien
il a complètement craqué
il fait fout des seins un petit échec au
courant
repose l'échange
après qu'il allait prendre en croiser un
nom et jouer à la place et faut aussi
c'est une sorte de proposition de nulle
tacite peut-être un petit roi G2 on se
quitte bons amis
fait des enchères tout ça
je pense qu'il va la jouer
et calme un petit peu mieux
alors il fait échecs
une petite nul et là
il est pas trop mal mais bon c'est pas
la nulle tout de suite quoi
ça joue en tout cas
il va le prendre je pense au final
[Musique]
peut-être
on essaie de jouer donc on s'attend à
ranger trois quand même
pareil pas bête
un pion B3
attention
c'est aussi possible quand j'essaie ça
fait échec il veut s'active avec sa tour
si le roi monte peut-être d'aller vers
G2 ou quoi après ce que c'est vraiment
une activation c'est que visuel on verra
bien
en tout cas voilà 4 c'est quand même la
logique d'aller vers l'avant
mais en H4 logique alors après on va
acheter
on va regarder les conséquences sur ton
G2 ou tout recettes ou des coups comme
ça en tout cas c'est la direction qu'il
aura blanc et de prendre
finale de pion elle est nulle ça se voit
c'est bon laquelle si elle te reprend
des trois c'est prendre des trois je
pense ça gagne pour les blancs mais si
elle te reprend des 7 ça fait nul ah bah
là il s'est bloqué tout seul
qui est étonnant
c'est qui l'autre déjà c'est un soir
et ça doit aller ouais
longtemps mais le problème ce qu'il est
mal au temps encore une fois il y aura
toujours eu ce problème dans tous ces
matchs un peu c'est cette pendule qui
n'aurait pas la gagne il devrait se
faire éliminer
près de très très beau match aujourd'hui
d'entrée
et on a hâte on a on a un patient de
[Musique]
ça va être assez extraordinaire et là il
laisse dommage de échec
F6
donc on va peut-être avoir deux
Armageddon en même temps incroyable
peut-être ou faire un H4 bien senti
des dames et ça va gagner tout seul on
échange c'est bon H4 deux armaguaisons
pour le prix d'un Fabien eh on s'y
attendait pas mais oui
ça va être extraordinaire ne rater
surtout pas ça après la pause c'est
quelques secondes peut-être que ordonne
ça tendait à juste gagner en cliquant et
ne rien faire
donc c'est bien fait nul on a eu le nez
creux on est parti voir cette partie
et voir ce moment clé ce roi H4 et donc
la Dame des 7 il va échanger les dames
une finale de rock qui va gagner toute
seule parce qu'il y a un deux contre un
aller loin
il y a quand même falloir faire un tout
petit peu attention
la tête dans tes 4 tu crois j'ai 5 rois
des 5 rois G4 c'est 6 3G3 ah non ça fait
dame beaucoup trop vite
mais oui peut-être problème c'est que
même on pourra faire un F5 F4 donner le
pion
on va voir F3
en plus encore un peu au cas où
dame j'ai 8
qui part
madame c'est 5 c'est le plus simple mais
bon ça ça gagne aussi
donc deux Armageddon à venir juste après
la pause reprenez bien votre force les
amis on revient très très vite
[Musique]
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surplus à du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechestre
ou les title
toastate.com/aventure tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroulent
en présentiel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chains.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ça repart et ça repart mesdames et
messieurs
ça repart avec
fais de
CFD
8D des brouettes ouais
on va voir un Siri faire au moins nul
avec les Noirs
c'était très mal passé on va voir
aujourd'hui bon en tout cas fais de self
qui joue une vente
peu théorique ça ressemble un petit quoi
en plus qu'est-ce que tu en penses de
position c'est pas je connais pas
tout à fait juste
avec un pion en G4 qui va sûrement chez
les idées de petits rock par contre le
rap peut rester au centre et où partir à
Zelda mais par la suite
voir comment ça continue partie au
combien important puisque le perdant
entre guillemets sera éliminé
pour de bon de manière définitive ce
sera pour l'année dernière partie dans
ce prestigieux tu en as
calcul donc première division je le
rappelle il y a pas de
relégation par contre en deuxième
division si vous posez la question parce
que là c'est super tu reléguais les
tournois ne sont pas attachés les uns
aux autres en quelque sorte
donc pour cela ça ne change pas grand
chose si je puis dire
sur la grande diagonale il défend son
cavalier et puis bon bah il compte quand
même jouer à 5 par la suite
on va reprendre F6 voilà
chasser ce fou des fois le G7 et donner
une petite caisse de fuite en E7 un F7
pardon en fait
c'est quand même une paire de fou côté
blanc
c'est sur l'autre côté noir
et il y aura pas de 3e chance
H5 jouer en tout cas
même ça attaque un peu la structure
blanche
et pour avoir ce plan H4 un peu avancé
pour la suite de la partie ça va gagner
aussi la case F5 pour les noirs et on se
dit non pour un cavalier plus tard donc
donc c'est pas bête qui a eu ces trois
jouets en tout cas il se développe
peut-être continuer par E4 peut-être
on va voir comment ça se développe en
tout cas il développe leur pièce les
deux joueurs qui se place on va avoir le
cas des deux places le premier coup de
butoir pour le moment on est encore
peut-être loin
même situation hier contre d'où ça tu
auras
s'il fait mieux aujourd'hui
en tout cas
bon c'est pas mal pour effet tout ça
parce qu'il est arrivé à échanger son
foot 15 ans et ensuite placer ses pions
sur case noire donc il a un fou de
quasiment couvre les cases blanches les
pions qui couvrent les cases noirs donc
ça joue bien ensemble tout ça
et
on va voir après avec les Blancs oui bon
mais les voilà peut-être arrivé à faire
F4 dès le prochain coup peut-être pour
ouvrir un peu les fous et avoir une
sorte de structure cette année de
couleur inversée
et on est bien loin
mais bon ça va jouer
et à l'avantage autant
normal dans un Armageddon
qui part du temps un saut
choisi un peu de temps la pendule mais
il a le droit de faire nul pour se
garantir d'avoir les Noirs
après vous me direz un philosophe aurait
pu enchaîner encore moins et avoir
lui-même les Noirs mais pourquoi pas
c'est une partie bien sûr le temps fait
partie du jeu et il est possible de
jouer pour faire tomber l'adversaire
donc assis ce qu'est la repartir vers A3
il est mal placé mais peut-être il
reviendra verser 4-1 jours ou en B1 D2
et il fera un petit trajet pour revenir
le fouget d'eau qui est mauvais il peut
quand même aller en H3 se retrouver de
nouvelles diagonale intéressante donc il
y a rien de fait
qui sort des sentiers battus mais
jouable
c'est pas ce qu'il a joué
il va peut-être
et changer
je sais pas je le sens plutôt être là
pour couvrir en quatre fois je crois
et bon je me tromper après si il prend
ses quatre le problème pour les Noirs ce
restaurant les cases blanches qui serait
complètement délaissé mais cette
structure de pions et
donc le fou pourra ensuite aller en H3
et rentrer quoi
F4 en tout cas voilà donc c'est un coup
qu'on se sentait arrivé de toute façon
ce genre structure et puis on prend donc
ça ouvre le jeu pour les fous mais en
même temps ça donne la case de 5 bien
sûr au cavalier noir donc ça peut être
intéressant
bon pour un camp comme pour l'autre
ça a l'air quand même bien solide pour
pour les noirs
[Musique]
peut-être pour ça que j'ai choisi ce
moment précis pour le jouer
reprise et est-ce qu'il garde le fond G3
ce qui fait de la F3
mais bon peut-être on peut donner le
pion et
d'un F2 qui est G6
un grand rock
sur le fameux centre
bon c'est toujours bien solide côté noir
prennent niveau pendule il a dit
conservé un peu moins de 4 minutes
d'avance donc ça peut ça peut être utile
ça peut s'avérer décisif
il faut aussi saut qui veut changer de
fou et surtout pouvoir faire grand rock
a priori
5 jouets
bon il élimine hein c'est fort cavalier
sur la case de 5 et on va voir cette
structure pion comme ça il va vouloir
jouer grand hack et peut-être vite
tourner un pour essayer de monter sur la
5e rangée et gagner le pur H5
alors qu'après ce match ne partait
surtout pas puisqu'il y aura
la demi-finale tant attendue Carlsen
kerwana voilà c'est juste un petit lever
de rideau une mise en bouche finalement
sur tout ce qui nous attend tout à
l'heure parce qu'on aura un match
carrément en quatre parties pas
seulement deux c'est vrai que là
peut-être on peut avoir une certaine
incertitude tu vois on a très vite
l'Armageddon alors que voilà quand même
quatre parties possiblement un armée
dans après donc une grande explication
de texte
ok oui
qui est parti chercher du jeu à Zelda
qui enchaîne les coups B5 bien joué il
peut pas y avoir 5 sur la dame C3
gagnerait le cavalier
la partie là
très bien joué
avoir la même position avec un pion en
B2
mais là
cette dame s'est ramené ces petits trous
sur cases noires
mais bon ça ça a l'air très fort mais il
a gagné un pion c'est déjà bien Laura
blanc va jamais être complètement en
sécurité
et il a aussi le plan tout bête à 5 à 4
à 3 dame B2 et 1 2 comme une fameuse
partie qu'on a fait sur la chaîne je
crois entre vous pouvez secouer fearujah
dans une française
variante
voilà ça devrait gagner
et donc Wesley petite méforme qui peut
continuer sa route alors à priorer dans
ce tournoi alors après avoir faut pas
déraper maintenant il a quand même moins
de 4 minutes on sait jamais c'est pas
fait mais il a une très bonne position
maintenant de bien trouver cette idée de
dame 7 et la dame qui est venue à
prendre ses 5 et exploiter les cases
noirs affaiblis chez l'adversaire
et maintenant il a l'option passer h si
l'option passer a qui peut arriver plus
tard le roi adverse un petit peu exposé
évidemment c'est la dame blanche de la
partie il y a du kb4 qui traînerait ce
qui est bien est complètement nul il n'a
aucune case pour sortir il va
probablement regretter un fait de CF la
deuxième partie avec les Blancs cette
finale et peut-être pu faire mieux quand
même ouais au moins s'il y aura H4 et
forcément la défense surtout qu'il avait
plus trop de temps je crois soit à ce
moment-là
alors attention la connexion aussi pour
Wesley plus qu'une barre
ça serait un beau tournant dans ce match
un ultime
clou du spectacle
magnifique partie en tout cas encore une
fois les deux joueurs qui nous ont
offert un spectacle
extraordinaire dans dans ce match
là ça a l'air perdu pour fait de CIF
de sacrifier
il veut pas voir qu'il est donc il tente
un truc il tente un va tout avec ce pion
ce pion j'ai passé
c'est bien joué de sa part en tout cas
après ça va probablement pas être
suffisant mais il tente de faire tourner
les événements et pas se subir en
faisant rien
c'est bien joué
parce que la dame à deux bon autant elle
peut être dangereuse elle est quand même
hors-jeu pour l'instant donc les Blancs
jouent avec une dame qui joue contre
une tour
encore un pion sur la route
mais bon c'est quand même le danger
maintenant principal
et
même si on fait damage 5 de toute façon
il y a toujours tout reprend ici ce qui
va roder sur dame prend H2 on restera
quand même avec une belle qualité
d'avance
et on sera débarrassé de ce pion ce
pionger qui était pénible
ah mais il aura réussi quand même à une
de certitude mais ouais quand
même bien gérer la papaye il a bien
envoyé le pion h la bien poussé
contrairement à hier un contrat
H2 et peut-être torcer 6 non il fait
Damas 5 il y a un joli coup aussi dans
ce style j'aime bien se défendait assez
7 et ça ramène la tour en face au roi on
essaie de me prendre les trois peut-être
c'est pas fait encore
très mauvaise série de coups c'est pas
c'est pas du grand Wesley
pas du grand Mendes non plus
et C4 se place et il va pouvoir
peut-être soutenir un petit peu ses
pions
5 enfin pour avancer soutenu par le
cavalier faut quand même arrivé à ne pas
se faire mater avec une dame D4 une tour
géant un moment mais pour l'instant
d'avancer et il a il y a deux vins
d'avance elle a pendule hallucinante
ça peut compter
attention il peut pas se contenter de la
nuit
je lui donne pas cher de sa peau dans
son quoi qu'il en soit quand bien il
passerait tout quand il va affronter des
joueurs chevronnés
ça sera un peu plus difficile
bon en même temps
pas évident là de voir comment comment
avancer côté blanc
et en C5
non non mais il est bien en fait je
pense qu'il va gagner
assez simple ça va devenir un jouet pour
les Noirs
C4 c'était un peu bloqué mais là il y a
une petite manœuvre sympa
de quel Magnus on va avoir
c'est étonnant ce qu'il a fait quand
même
c'est 5
je pense qu'il avait
moins de 2 minutes il va faire F4
bizarre aussi mais bon il veut descendre
en fait je comprends
pas
[Musique]
et maintenant faut jouer la pendule à
fond il y a pas trop le choix
parce que il y a plus de sport de gagner
ça aux échecs
par contre en cliquant
c'est un pion
c'est 5 faire le truc hyper logique
normal
il a voulu être malin
il a mal géré sa pendule parce qu'il a
joué un truc qui aurait pu marcher
évidemment mais
il faut être précis c'est vrai quand tu
as des 3 minutes d'avance peut-être ton
salaire pour en dépenser une et de
précis à ce moment où ça joue la
c'est ça qui est important quoi on
n'était pas avec 30 secondes chacun
il va pas y arriver
parti bizarre
ah il est arrivé on rajoute j'ai
l'impression
ah donc là bon
parcours je comprends même pas l'intérêt
de l'armée donc on fait comme ça en fait
c'est tellement mieux d'avoir les noirs
après c'est les enchères
dans l'autre match
[Musique]
ça joue encore dans l'autre match
de l'impression d'être gagnant et qui
enfin
donc beaucoup plus de temps que Wesley
tu fais B7 et Tour Eiffel non
rien en cause maintenant dès que le roi
vapoter le bouton pour lui mettre un
échec et à la dame il a en G7 il se
cache
mais il est bloqué là-bas il peut rien
faire d'autre que de rester en G7 si
bien F-7 il y aura ton âge 8 si on
réussit sur un tour G8 et donc on va
pouvoir monter
à la bordage et peut-être venir verser 6
par là-bas
en H7 tu mets le rang F5 et la tour sera
en V6
à gagner mais j'ai l'impression qu'il
galère un peu
ne quittez pas après cette partie il y
aura une petite pause avant
le feu d'artifice
vous n'avez encore rien vu vous n'avez
encore rien vu
alors il veut F4 G5 et prendre du roi et
garder un pion effacé je pense
faut pas un Pione je passais dans ces
cas de figure ça sert à rien
si tu veux
quand même
passé c'est complètement gagnant quoi
bon en même temps il peut mettre le roi
n'importe où
pas trop compris la finale mais ça
suffit
bon après cela
est pas grand chose à faire ici
bon petit joueur
je l'ai croisé souvent dans les open
espagnol
au long de ma vie de joueur donc je
connais c'est un bon bonjour
un gars solide pour
[Musique]
j'ai toujours un peu les mêmes
ouvertures
et que les Blancs c'était plutôt un
joueur de sorte de Réty ou de D4
et donc le fameux G5
qui va donner le pion passé F qui sera
décisif puisque le roi pourra plus
rester en G7 et ça sera la place à la
Tour Blanche la semaine dans le coin
pour soutenir son pion et vous gagnez la
tour adverse
si on fait ça gagne ou pas
je suis pas sûr
moi
il aurait voulu et toi
et voilà
le truc qu'on voulait
il évite quand même
même s'il y avait pas
on sait pas pourquoi ça continue
et voilà
qualification donc du Tour de Saga et de
Wesley sceaux pour le prochain tour du
loser bracket ils seront rejoints donc
par les perdants
des matchs qu'on va regarder tout à
l'heure et donc je vous propose qu'on se
rejoigne donc pour pour les gros matchs
maintenant à tout de suite ne quittez
pas on revient après la pause
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechesse
ou les title tussday
chase.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présence ciel ou en ligne vivez
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition aux pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess.com/avent ou
c'est bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ça y est je vois que c'est reparti
non pour cette première ronde
carbonate débute avec les pièces
blanches et c'est une démence sicilienne
donc pas de E4 à 6 aujourd'hui et E4 C5
F3 E6 D4 prise ky6 en time man of the
sicilienne qui est 7 ou 3 à 6 et G4
coffensif H6 H4 voilà donc c'est rien de
démarrer
et on va voir une un beau combat on
espère entre deux gros joueurs donc même
jusqu'à Arsène qu'on ne présente plus et
fabino carwana qui était son challenger
lors du championnats du monde en 2018
qui atteint un classement Elo
de
2832 quand il jouait ce match là et
peut-être qu'il a même eu plus en
45 même en publier je pense c'était son
max mais
45 mais peut-être je sais pas en tout
cas lors du match il est 32
matchs en perspective
c'est l'équivalent j'ai envie de te dire
d'un Djokovic mais bon ce serait
ne pas faire honneur à ce match quand
même parce que c'est une demi-finale et
de l'autre côté je crois que c'est quart
de finale simplement
ça reste au dessus
donc taille manov Fab bon on va voir si
Carlsen je vous le match à fond ou pas
mais il semble plus déterminé qu'il y a
oh ben je crois qu'il était aussi
déterminé telle marche qui pouvait se
permettre des petites fantaisies
donc il a quand même bouffé un pion mais
Faby n'a pas gaffé il l'a donné et il te
dit ouais mais je suis bien développé
je suis bien développé toutes les pièces
sont en jeu
voilà après c'est très concret c'est pas
suffit pas de juste jouer comme ça mais
on peut voir qu'il y a probablement
certaines petites condensation
je veux bien le croire toute façon en
général bien assez vite dessus
formation importante Fabien
c'est 82 ou 83 2 82 et
89 en
on va dire
tout le monde dit ça déjà
en temps intermédiaire quoi enfin un
truc qui n'a jamais été publié mais en
temps réel
on peut trouver sur le site de 1700
chess
à réfléchit
position intéressante
pour Fabien
ouais bon au moins
on va dire c'est pas une position qui
bouge pas
c'est clairement une position agressive
pour les blancs toutes les pièces sont
en jeu en fait même le fouet fin qui
n'est pas développé il a quand même des
diagonales ouvertes à droite à gauche
donc
ça c'est cool et il peut continuer soit
à part G5 G6 aller ouvert des brèches
une suite assez logique on avait le
temps avec les Blancs après après voilà
il peut y avoir des coups agressifs
comme un cahier des cinq qui se sacrifie
au milieu pour voir la colonne ou quoi
donc la calife6 jouait
et deux hommes qui s'étaient affrontés
hier avant-hier je vais aller jouer le
tournoi du Grand Chester et tournoi
s'enchaînent aux échecs avec les mêmes
joueurs ah c'est souvent le cas
sont des des classico en quelque part
des matchs que l'on peut suivre et
suivre de semaine en semaine
sans ne jamais se lasser on va peut-être
dû déjà deux trois ans
c'est toujours un plaisir
bien évidemment
point faible du tennis d'ailleurs les
gens
surtout là dans des tournois ou l'enjeu
et si élevé entre le grand cheese tour
Zagreb qui est quand même un énorme
tournoi à ajouter à son palmarès c'est
ce miel
c'était 45
j'étais à un point près du tout pile
mais mon difficile un de se rappeler de
tout ça
en tout cas ça joue bien
ouais
peut-être pour la première fois
réellement de la partie
attention de pas se faire prendre à
contre-pied avec ses pièces un foug2
d'après fort un an la diagonale
ça peut faire mal
comment cet accord
passe pas forcément le filet
complexe en tout cas
peut-être quand même jouer G5 ça reste
un coup envisagé j'imagine peut-être un
coup aussi comme cavalier H5 alors qu'il
y a bien la structure après qu'elle va
aller prendre si on prend mais qui
ouvrira la colonne g à la tour et
empêcherait refuger de se développer et
sur quel âge 5 si tu le prends pas bon
au moins il est là il est chiant il sort
pas le fouet fuite et bon tu peux jouer
tout ça ici en intercal en fougère
donc effectivement c'est mérite
réflexion toute façon on a vu que les
parties étaient assez lente 15 minutes
ça se bien bien le temps de la réflexion
réponse immédiate dans la diagonale
c'est pas l'ascendant sur cette démonel
bien évidemment
je m'y attendais pas trop à ce coup je
dois dire mais
et ne pas laisser cavaler le 4
je vais l'embêter ok 3 pour tenir les
cases
[Musique]
mais bon j'étais plus enthousiaste avec
ses conversations il y a quelques coups
que maintenant je veux dire
5 après gagner le pion des 7
ouais ça me pas très très réalisable à
cause de G5 effectivement qui chasserait
le calife 6 de la défense de décès pour
l'instant ça va il y a la dame B7 qui
qui est dédiée à cette tâche
c'est maintenant on tourne Magnus de
réfléchir
chaque coup est important ici
ils sont trop concrètes
très compliqué
[Musique]
long de la colonne c'est en face du roi
blanc donc souvent on a l'habitude de
rager par roi B1 dans la situation
il faut considérer peut-être j'ai 5 quoi
qu'il en soit
il joue
on est en train de faire mal
à faire juste au prochain c'est quand
même l'air d'être assez
offensif hein tout à fait alors
peut-être le choix défensif parce que
des 5
pour échanger des pièces c'est-à-dire
que peut-être rendre le pion s'il y a
qu'à y prendre
puis on prend et entrer dans une finale
comme ça c'est peut-être une option pour
ne pas prendre de risques
c'est une belle option
surtout qu'au bout du bout tu peux
toujours envisager avec la tourage F8
entre en jeu en H2 tension la septième
donc quand même verse toujours sympa
alors les blancs pourraient courir
évidemment pour tourner deux ou quoi
mais
on sent pas mis en danger avec les Noirs
alors il a choisi qui j'évite
étonnant retour vers l'arrière mais bon
son qualitat attaquer et en gros c'était
soit des 5 voisins
le plus ambitieux qui est certain mais
bon
le développement il est nul quoi
quasiment mais bon les tours qui jouent
et les blancs ils ont du mal à t'ouvrir
la position pour l'instant c'était assez
bas placé sur l'échiquier
mais ce qui est j'évite aussi un qui
peut avoir dans de bonbons une fois que
ça sera revenu au 7 il a une belle case
en F5 il sera très stable
et il couvre pas mal de choses donc
finalement ça car on a de vide prouver
pourquoi il a donné un pion
sinon il s'expose
une lourde défaite
ça pourrait aller très vite après
faire la première avec les Blancs
et il a choisi fout des quatre
bah écoute fout des quatre pas si mal
mais il faut au centre
diagonale de l'autre côté maintenant
vers G7 les Noirs vraiment se développer
mais là on est plus dans la recherche de
compensation vite fait à long terme que
quelque chose de direct
c'est plus un coup de placement qu'autre
chose
apparemment les Noirs ont du mal à
terminer leur développement
je vais me dire envie de terminer leur
développement parce que
MC6 il se replace il travaille de
concert avec sa tour comme ça la Dame
des deux est assez bloquée à des
sensations
B4 un jour ou quoi parce qu'il y a dame
français de maths
donc
préparer une défense avec soit un tour
G2 qui laissera la dame les mains libres
soit roi B1 de toute façon qu'on aime
bien faire
pour pouvoir aller se cacher dans
l'angle si jamais sans lever de ce
vis-à-vis peut-être l'hiver le pioncer
et ou avoir Torcé un qui peut parfois
être une idée alors c'est C3 pour ouvrir
un nouveau front sur les dames
pendant que les Noirs ont toutes ces
pièces bloquées là-bas elle est loin
mais bon quand faut-il y arriver
mais bon c'est des potions jamais simple
à jouer parce que pas trop
classique et donc obligé de réfléchir
très vite
un peu la beauté du jeu qu'on arrête je
sors
tu sors des sentiers battus
tu vas créer des nouvelles idées trouver
des nouvelles harmonie avec les pièces
c'est pas forcément en position
habituelle
c'est très beau
tout
qui vient un peu de toucher ce qu'il y
avait
un peu beaucoup même il le touche il le
touche complètement
mais
je sais pas donc qu'est-ce qui crée
réellement une menace ici j'ai pas
l'impression
et voilà quoi
après peut-être d'un point F3 rose aussi
avec
[Musique]
des gros orages
à Dijon ouais cette partie de la France
là dans l'est du pays c'était annoncé
donc si vous abris
je sais pas
je sais pas mais peut-être Météo France
café son fou en B2 c'est pas mal c'est
le fameux fou que tu aimes bien
quand même
des fois il attaque un peu de l'autre
côté il est plus encombrant le long de
la colonne D donc en fait il y a plus de
dame prend F3 puisque il y a le pion
dessin bien sûr qui sauterait direct et
le mat à venir donc
voilà après les condensations restent
maigres pour un pion c'est-à-dire que ça
joue toujours mais on voit rien de
probant côté blanc
proéminent
mais en même temps
la récompense est grande si tu navigue
bien puisque tu as besoin de plus et que
finalement tu arriveras à te mettre en
place
petit
en tout cas je l'aime bien clairement
c'était la case qui était tout indiquée
une fois qu'il a choisi de faire kg 8 il
est ce trajet vers recette F5 naturelle
et maintenant il est arrivé à
destination donc il est là il y a plus
aucun pion pour le chasser et il
contrôle pas mal de cases dans le camp
adverse et aussi la case G7 le pion là
qui est défendu maintenant le fou pourra
éventuellement sortir de cette tanière
en fuite si tu le veux
ah bah ouais mais peut-être même noir
enfin je crois que c'était plus rapide
depuis 5 ans d'après ce que j'avais lu
donc oui enfin
sans déconner quoi enfin j'ai pas vous
dehors par plaisir quoi
et à Saint-Étienne
on n'est pas dans les départements cités
mais peut-être qu'il va avoir une belle
rage quand même
une visiteuse
qui est venu
supportrice de Magnus
en tout cas ça joue encore dans cette
partie entre Carole avec 47
jours ce problème de température aussi
qui n'a pas réussi à résoudre
27 chez lui qui pourrait lui compter la
partie regarde le COD est un peu monté
je crois qu'il était à 732 quand on
avait regardé tout à l'heure il me
semble qu'il a 760 maintenant
qu'il a pris 22
ppm de plus de
tu t'es censé faire un truc et puis bon
tu te retrouves tu sais pas trop ce que
tu as fait quoi en fait
tu sens qu'un truc qui tourne pas trop
rond alors ça veut pas dire que tu vas
perdre
parce que bon
c'est encore loin d'être fait mais
bon il y a plus que 3 minutes quoi qu'il
en soit entre 6 pour Magnus même si 46 +
+ 7 que 6
donc ça aussi ça peut jouer en la
défaveur de joueur américain
tiens plus trop de temps on lui voit pas
de plan très clair ici dans la position
ça
suit il choisit qu'il y ait des trois
3 donc probablement qu'il aimerait
bondir en E5 peut-être faire foudre
mais on le prendrait
coup de développement et de contrôle
les pièces sortent du kf5 est bien et
défend et le fou des 6 et surtout le
purger 7 le four entre en jeu la tourage
4 elle est bien elle contrôle le plein
de cases aussi le contrôle de cette
colonage si besoin pour mettre le rang
E7 un jour donc il y a le 5 quand même
choisi par par Fabiano et a priori on
était là pour le prendre celui-là
oh que oui
il était venu pour le prendre
bon bah tu restes avec un bidon de plus
il y a une pièce en moins sur les
et tout va plutôt bien
d'ici je veux être avec le four ça va
libérer la dame dans ses mouvements vu
qu'il y a plus d'oreilles
et d'ailleurs peut-être même qu'il faut
rassure ensuite par dame prend F3
ça a l'air d'être la cata
et prendre ce pion
mais la partie est quasiment parfaite un
côté
Carlson assez impressionnant facile
encore une fois très facile il encaissé
le pion il l'a dit gérer
il enfonce le clou
et il a défoncé
un roubaf Djokovic un petit peu
étouffé
de l'adversaire
pas grand chose à se reprocher Fabien
finalement
bah des fois tu
peux changer la merde jouer avec moi en
cadence peut-être
ça n'arrive pas
ouais mais la famille il a tenté à me
prendre la gorge adversaire en donnant
ce pion très tôt dans la partie pour un
beau développement etc mais après il a
pas su trouver les coups la différence
se fait peut-être en retour aussi
finalement
bagnus qui force à jouer plus de coups
que caroanna la position était
probablement pas si mauvaise pendant
longtemps mais
malgré les pièces noires on sent que il
peut très très vite mettre sous pression
et deux billions de plus donc pour Manu
5e d'aller chercher sur F3 voilà il a
pas vu pourquoi ne pas le prendre donc
il y va et il a bien raison
depuis on en a besoin
toujours aussi dominant majestueux
[Musique]
parce que ça met un petit muret ça se
trouve B2 et ça consolide tout ça on
n'ouvre pas la tour G1 d'ailleurs
marrant que cette tour géant était
beaucoup moins utile que la tour HD noir
un jouet donc la tourangée qui servait
pas grand chose comme on le disait elle
revient à l'attaque le pion aussi
très très facile
et
ce mur
trop solide
tu as quasiment envie d'abandonner ce
genre de position
tour de
pas trop ça qui fait peur quoi
mais j'aime bien c'est une belle partie
de l'anus pour l'instant
sans faille je pense
ça défend tout
bien sûr qui viendra échanger encore une
tour
quand même nous ce qui prend son temps
pour bien conclure tout ça
il souffle avant de jouer
on y va réussir à conclure
et de nombreuses options toute façon il
peut pas se tromper maintenant quoi
qu'il choisisse ce sera des bons choix
il reste deux minutes 15
juste pas trop trop traîner pour rien
oui
ça a replacer la dame en 4 qui sera
peut-être encore mieux
ça rayonne
il faut pouvoir la maintenir sur de
telles cases mais si on peut
y refuse mais il peut même pas vraiment
attaquer G7 puisque
qui défend tout
très très facile
mais bon
il faut pas trop traîner pour rien
il y a plein de bons coups comme dit
il y a plein de bon coup
il a choisi des cinq bon c'est très bien
ça crée une structure de pions
c'est très solide c'est soutenu par le
pion aussi à trois pour casser ce pion
B4 et donne un peu de vie au fou mais
bon
c'est pas vraiment un problème
je suppose
qui est tout ça comme des perles c'est
un peu la cata quoi
maintenant
OK
ça encadrer
et ben voilà c'est une victoire de
Magnus Carlson dans cette première
partie on va aller voir ce qui se passe
[Musique]
et qui a perdu
assez vite
en fait il a laissé
voyante intéressante à jouer par Abdou
qui a joué ultra tactique il avait l'air
de connaître waouh il a toujours été un
peu jusque là
il est préparé une petite variante piège
rapidement mesdames et messieurs on se
retrouve très bientôt pour
la suite de ce tournoi un tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est reparti superbe match Fabien
menant 0 un côté côté caroanna
toujours pas réglé ses problèmes de
température à domicile c'est quand même
vraiment embêtant il
a une mauvaise utilisation de
[Musique]
pour remettre de l'air frais dans la
maison
très très embêtant Fabien
il suit un petit peu
terrible ça
mené au score et il fait pas c'est pas
les efforts il peut s'en vouloir en plus
de cette première partie il était pas si
loin c'était serré il a eu les occasions
de revenir dedans
en même temps
il est fermé la porte quoi
il est en dessous c'était trop fort côté
Magnus
donc il a pris en D4 qui est six dames
des deux G6
à 4 assez vite avec les noirs
faudrait recoller immédiatement
va être difficile à stopper Magnus dans
ce tournoi comme toujours
elles sont pas le marais
un peu plus
déjà en grande forme
c'était imposé devant tout le monde pour
ajouter encore un titre à sa liste à sa
longue liste
dommage
dommage ouais
c'était même plus qu'un équivalent
c'était une copie conforme ce sont en
termes de format ou de
prestige ou d'audience évidemment quand
Chester Paris qui était un des tournois
très attendus du calendrier mondial
qui a disparu
peut-être de sponsor et c'est assez
étonnant
face au succès retentissant de cette
épreuve
peut-être un problème de toi rétractable
il faut
en tout cas si Magnus réussit à
s'imposer dans cette partie le match
sera déjà
[Musique]
comme dit on va voir à 5 à 4 rapide
ouais
les blancs c'est non un jeu de pièces
relativement actif les blancs ils ont
ils ont une belle case en dessin un
avant-poste donc pour aller planter un
cavalier de sucre sera toujours un peu
pénible à gérer dès que tu fais ces 6 tu
fais sur le cavalière pousser ou
s'échange mais après c'est des sites
qu'il n'y ait un peu faible ou alors
sinon faut supporter ce qu'il y a eu en
dessin
donc c'est un peu le problème et si
jamais tu venais à le prendre alors déjà
tu pourras le remplacer par un autre
mais aussi l'autre option c'est de
prendre du pion
pour trouver la colonne C qui nous reste
semi-ouverte et qui a tapé sur le pion
C7 cette fois-ci
donc aquattro c'est parti alors l'idée
c'est que certes ce pion est en prise 4
il y avait du qui est prend C4 qui peut
être aimé explosif
le Magnus qui ne touche surtout pas à ça
qui regarde cette petite structure
intacte pour pour tout défendre
mais du coup maintenant B3 un peu plus
vulnérable et aussi la case B4
un cavalier aussi pour aller en D7 C5
pour attaquer B3 donc ça laisse toujours
des des petites idées si vous voulez
partir en tout cas pour le moment oui
de développement
il se développe
cette emprise mais comme d'hab si on
fait fou prend il y aura sûrement tourbé
8 et tu reprends B3 et les blancs là
serait pas très content de perdre ce
pion B parce que ça active à la tour
adverse et surtout de foncé 4
deviendrait clairement une cible
préparer un G4 peut-être suivi d'un G5
dans un contrôle des cases si jamais lui
vient d'idée de faire le 4 il aurait pas
de fouger 4 attaquant la tour et pour
faire du foie F3 ou du cahier F3 après
donc
ça fait des choses
H5 jouets de toute façon ça évite les G4
et ça peut permettre d'envoyer un petit
H4 un jour peut-être si jamais
partie animée pour le moment extrêmement
intéressant
un bijou Fabien
un bijou un nouveau bijou
et on va voir comment comment ça tourne
tout ça
la position
essaye d'enfoncer le coup tout de suite
ou si il va être plus en mode gestion
gestion
voilà maintenant qu'il a un point
d'avance qui va remporté en rappel la
première partie avec les pièces noires
le break en ce match donc si maintien
loi jusqu'au bout ça sera la victoire
ouverte
mais bon au final c'est pas complètement
faux non plus
la plus besoin de faire particulièrement
le jeu il peut jouer tranquille il avait
fait
des petites finales bon bah je trouve
qu'il les gagnait mais si jamais il
gagnait pas que c'est nulle ça allait
aussi quoi
3h20 de jeu aujourd'hui avec un
demi-finale
pour le plaisir des fans d'échec qui
doivent se délecter
de ces parties et peut-être qu'on est
qu'à 1000 journées là on pourrait avoir
encore quatre parties à venir
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
après je sais pas j'imagine mal Fabienne
en revenir en ce match mais il y a
peut-être le match
avec les pièces noires non il a gagné
sans réfléchit en tout cas on va laisser
les joueurs on leur temps puisque on a
un peu fait le tour de la position on va
les laisser jouer un c'est aussi ça
l'intérêt des échecs que les joueurs
jouent les coups
mais c'est une potion je sais pas qui
m'a l'air plus plaisante que tu es
Magnus quoi qu'il en soit
pression d'espace quoi
un peu plus d'espace la case des 5 un
peu qu'on peut occuper elle est noire
ils sont plus dans la réaction par
rapport à ce que font les blancs mais
ils peuvent pas par eux-mêmes tout d'un
coup
choisir trop ce qui se passe donc
je trouve jamais ça trop simple à jouer
ça ne l'est pas
j'aurais juste une journée un peu
particulière jeudi il y aura finalement
les demi-finales et la finale de je vous
envoie
des deux parties
ça peut être un peu court
on sera peut-être pas bien sûr mais bon
moi pour les les finales du loser
bracket j'aurais bien remis un bo4
personnellement oui
et
à ce moment-là peut-être que pour la
vraie grande finale
pourrait se faire une belle journée qui
commence à 10 heures du mat
et
tout son final quoi tu vois
j'ai du mal à regarder
un petit peu comme ça
c'est dommage
mais c'était beau
ça monte un peu la tour au combat et
elle pourra peut-être venir en B6 par la
suite ce qui était immédiatement coupé
un camion descend on parlait qui pouvait
sauter sur sur ces cases centrales
[Musique]
c'est tout l'intérêt de cette position
et d'ailleurs c'est c'est pour ça qu'il
avait joué qui avait les H3 au début de
la partie puis cavalier F4 pour être là
quoi
un peu dans les pâtes je sais pas c'est
un peu différent mais bon sûrement
jouable aussi
et après il y avait effectivement
donc il interdit la tour
à la tour la caisse B6 et donc si on
veut se débarrasser de trucs il faudra
faire ses 6 donc un coup toujours bien
peser le pour et le contre le pour il
est très clair c'est qu'on dégage de
cahier de dessin
mais le contre et ben c'est que le pion
des 6 n'a plus son pion C7 pour le
soutenir et donc on le cavalier bougera
attaquer alors parfois les noirs peuvent
même le donner pour s'activer
et puis c'est si ça offre aussi la
possibilité de sortir la dame quoi
donc
Madame c'est pour arriver vers BCI ou
à 5 parfois enfin là plutôt baissé
d'ailleurs dans le cas échéant
[Musique]
dans le chats
il est pas loin il parle en même temps
quoi
c'est un peu bizarre
français en Coupe d'Europe dans les
années 90 la grande
tu sais pas mais en fait non
mais en fait sur tous les points
importants
[Musique]
une pression sur le cavalier
7 quand même
tu te mets bien dans le match après
en tout cas peut-être c'est 5 à regarder
[Musique]
il peut pas prendre donc j'imagine
tomber 5
et puis on prend des 6
e de plus
[Musique]
je sais pas trop si on n'est pas un peu
fragile avec tous nos pièces ici ou là
mais bon c'est 5 c'est clairement le
coup que tu as envie de faire pour
profiter un peu de tomber si un peu
étrange et de se vis-à-vis de la colonne
quoi
donc c'est la ligne regarder c'est 5 ans
et 5 c'est prendre
qui télécharge leur partie sur M6 après
faire le bilan
ces jours là je suis pas sûr
je pense qu'un certain niveau tu sais
faire le bilan un peu tout seul quoi
au niveau débutant c'est vraiment utile
Fab bah ouais c'est pas de revoir tes
parties déjà
et puis donc de travailler sur les
points précis alors après c'est aussi le
rôle en général d'un entraîneur mais là
c'est un entraîneur informatisé
qui qui te scanne tout de manière très
très objective quoi c'est quand même
moins cher qu'un entraîneur si possible
je sais pas trop le coup j'ai plus les
abonnements mais
c'est moins cher
d'avoir peu de plusieurs abonnements
alors
c'est ce que j'avais
mais l'ordi il peut faire la même avec
les Français 4 qui donne le même
position avec un pion de plus
ce qui est
[Musique]
jouer mais alors peut-être qu'il est
français c'est intermédiaire c'était
important et d'apprendre du coup bon en
tout cas clairement un peu plus parler
davantage pour les blancs mais
on peut pas avoir en parler davantage
pour les Noirs non plus il va faire 3 et
foot des cinq
jouets donc c'est un petit coup de
placement c'est pas mal attends le
contrôle des cases intéressantes
pas encore tout simple à côté blanc
parce que il y a aussi la tour qui peut
arriver en B2 peut-être
il faut encore retrouver deux trois
petits coups
j'ai pas besoin de sortir les gros barbe
non plus mais être un petit peu précises
il est à l'aise un peu
filé
une absence
il veut quoi
[Musique]
il change ce fou qui tient des cases le
roi blanc un petit peu les trois je
ferais bien un petit coup droit G2 perso
je me serais prendre un F3 pour prendre
du pion
et je me mets dans mon petit
hamac là au milieu tranquille et bien
protégé quand même
c'est pas c'est bien joué
pas du grand jeu mais bon ça devrait
tenir
il serrer les boulons quoi
et pas facile c'est match d'être
impérial sur toute la durée
on va voir comment ça se termine
alors j'ai deux jouets Fabiano qui
réfléchit il voit qu'il est un peu mieux
mais
ça peut passer ou quoi
merci
[Musique]
vraiment la première fois il y avait pas
plusieurs coups d'affilée
bien joué
il faut faire F4 toute façon on n'a pas
bien le choix
mais il va le faire
c'est un peu à contrecœur
parce que ça vaut la troisième rangée ça
voulait diagonale contre le roi etc mais
en même temps ça dépend le pion ça
permet de faire dame prend des 6
maintenant je pense qu'il va la perdre
puisque il prend du temps il est mal à
la pendule contrairement à la partie
précédente où il devenait de la tête et
des épaules
s'accroche mais il est venu prendre ce
pion H4 important pour défendre ce pion
H3 qui est vital pour ce roi
attention
une belle séquence là quand même
il suit à fond quoi
[Musique]
il a pas perdu son temps pour rien
Magnus
c'est une défense très précise qui a été
pas rendu encore les armes dans ce match
qui a pris sa chance ici ça va peut-être
pas suffisant cette partie mais bon et
la prochaine il va repartir au combat
d'un F3 jouer
en croiser a priori un roi je serai
dommage sur la dame bref
il peut avoir à défendre une finale avec
un pion de moins
en tout cas puis on passe
après
juste pas envie de prime abord mais
peut-être il peut se dire je bouge à ce
moment-là je perds pas mon pion H3 et
que c'est cool mais bon alors il a
choisi un
donc évidemment les Noirs prendre
le pion F si le souhaite mais il y a pas
Échec déjà donc c'est une différence
dans des 8 donc ça laisse de me prendre
H3 que j'avais en tête aussi
avoir
donc là ça se tente encore côté noir
c'est pas fait qu'il ne gagne pas
c'est loin d'être fait
et ma tête
3 2
[Musique]
qui est quand même la tout principal des
normes faudrait pouvoir
avancer espion mais c'est vrai que là
pour l'instant ce que j'ai 5 est pas mal
joué parce que il enferme le rat noir
dans une petite boîte là-bas et si les
blancs arrivaient avec deux tours sur la
réseau de maths
tu auras 4 échecs
qui est vraiment tout seul et la
tendance va être bien placé derrière
puis on passait c'est et ça va
direct
la meilleure chance
bon mais il y a des beaucoup de jeux de
part et d'autre qui joue bien les coups
pour attaquer mais en face ça défend ça
défend
ça on avait vu la variante le problème
c'est que la tour se met derrière le
pion c'est trop dur d'avancer le roi
noir ne sort pas
ils sont en train de jouer
ils veulent avec les blancs
à la fin de cette partie
les vannes avec les Blancs qui essayent
qui a un pion de plus
encore un roi qui pourra pas trop
participer au jeu
mais le pion qui peut un petit peu
avancer peut-être aller jusqu'à 6
à certains moments
je pense il peut la gagner les bonnes il
peut il va essayer
en train de faire nul
on va quand même s'assurer
côté
il va y arriver
ok donc ça c'est nul on vend les bonnes
alors si l'emporte ou pas donc Magnus
qui garde l'avantage en ce match un et
demi à 0,5 et chez Levan à rognan donc
opposé
me dire
un pion de plus ce pion il en a 6 il ne
demande qu'à avancer d'où ce couteau
c'est ça pour l'accueillir sur la case à
7 à plus qu'à une case de promotion mais
ça serait une autre histoire pour les
plus loin
puisqu'il y a le fouet 4 et la tour à
deux qui surprotage cette case à 8 le
roi j'ai un participe pas trop le fouet
on sait pas trop le mettre
ça tient le choc côté ouzbek
qui active
le roi
je sais pas comment il va peut
progresser à partir de maintenant
la tourtière le pion
on va espérer une gaffe ou une déco
il veut à 8 intermédiaires
et fu F3 il veut son F3
le drame
bon au moins les vannes il a fait un
progrès qui est peut-être que symbolique
mais il est monté d'une rangée
ce roi qui est un peu moins bloqué que
peut-être zigzag et via E1 et partir un
peu là-bas vers la dame
on est au max bon truc chasse ses tours
de la seconde rangée parce qu'elle peut
pas rester
dames du coup la tour va devoir aller à
3 en A4 en quelque part par là et
peut-être le roi va repartir vers des
deux
trois voilà essayer de monter par là
haut
la belle et fort en tout cas
et qui en pose
donc c'était pas facile
[Musique]
il y a des idées
tenter de monter le roi là il va perdre
le pion à H si il a bien aimé le garder
mais voilà
ça va laisser aussi des opportunités
peut-être des fois de rentrer des
finales Torfou contre tour si jamais le
fou devait se terrifiant à huit un jour
au final nul théorique mais bon on
pratique jamais si simple surtout avec
peu de temps la pendule si tu échange le
fou contre le fou et la tour contre le
pion c'est nul maintenant
et oui
on va pouvoir faire plus que ça en plus
qui est encore une fois très bien
défendu très bon joueur
[Musique]
avec le fond à 6
ça ferait mieux quand même
et match nul donc les deux joueurs qui
avaient pris l'avantage reste devant on
se retrouve dans quelques minutes pour
la suite du tournoi merci à tous à tout
de suite saviez-vous que vous pouvez
pimenter vos parties en ligne et vous
analysez avec des emojis il vous suffit
de cliquer sur l'icône emoji puis de
sélectionner votre emoji et de cliquer
avec le bouton gauche de la souris sur
l'échiquier vous pouvez choisir parmi
une multitude de notation de coûts
d'émoticônes et même vos personnalités
préférées du monde des échecs des
émoticônes et les emojis disparaître au
bout de quelques secondes en revanche
notations de coûts et les animations
spéciales restent sur l'échiquier
jusqu'à ce qu'elles soient effacées pour
ce faire il suffit de cliquer avec le
bouton gauche de la souris sur l'emoji
ou de cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
essayez tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
et c'est reparti dans cette affrontement
entre Fabien et Magnus Carlson et
Fabiano donc qui a joué E4 et on est
dans une Sicilienne
dans une Sicilienne et la vente qu'on
avait vu dans la partie entre so et
fedocef donc c'est
Rosso limo avec
E5 au troisième coup
sauf que si vous souvenez soit pour
jouer sur la case et là dans famille je
vais vite vite des quatre donc qui
devrait être un coup dès maintenant
après on peut aussi jouer un coup comme
A4 évidemment pour essayer de
challenger les Noirs
B5 souvent c'est un coup quand même bien
faire
mais des cadres bien sûr et très logique
dès maintenant
coup tout à fait jouable
et seulement des trois donc des trois
aussi tout à fait possible plus
tranquille les blancs qui vont vouloir
jouer un peu comme dans une Espagnole ce
genre plan et peut-être des cas bien
évidemment il est renoncent pas pour
autant une journée peut-être plus tard
faut trois jouets donc petit à côté côté
Magnus kbdo
maintenant on peut s'attendre peut-être
un coup comme tout re 8 peut-être ou
sans rien ce fou qui bougerait
vous êtes vers recette pour que le pion
dé soit libéré qu'il en décide ou en
dessin
je sais pas trop quel coup ouais
simplement voilà pour libérer alors il
pouvait pas aller en C7 l'option était
attaqué donc il y a besoin d'un fou sur
cette diagonale à 4 donc il vient
menacer puis on prend tant pis il
s'enlève du vis-à-vis donc les blancs
peuvent prendre s'ils ont envie ou pas
en B5 bon ils peuvent prendre évidemment
ça vaut la tour sur la Colonna donc
pourquoi pas
demande le score mais le score donc est
de 1 et demi à 0,5 pour pour Carlson
qui est un scène qui a gagné la première
manche dans ce match de 4 parties
et
donc là c'est la partie numéro 3 il a
gagné la première nul dans la seconde et
voilà
donc Fabiano qui replace le fond en B3
toujours mieux passer quand même sur
cette diagonale qui cite derrière ses
pions
et au passage ça évite que les normes
joue le coup des 5 donc il s'attendait 6
il vient se placer ici donc sur la belle
case centrale il attaque le cavalier
donc a priori un coup comme d'hab c'est
ça devra défendre mais il a plutôt
choisi de venir en E8 alors je sais pas
exactement
pourquoi plus ce vide que c'est 7 mais
pourquoi pas
ça défend de toute façon le cavalier et
j'imagine qu'il aimerait bien poursuivre
avec un coup comme comme vous aussi a
priori à l'avenir
alors peut-être que la dame serait mieux
ici si jamais il veut replacer le fou
par là-bas un jour j'en sais rien on
verra ce qui l'entête il a joué assez
vite donc ça lui semblait très naturel
et maintenant à Fabiano de jouer donc il
a mis ses pièces en place
c'est plutôt cohérent tout ce qu'il a
fait jusque là mais bon
faut-il trouver une suite à tout ça
donc ça pourrait de tenter des cadres
voilà ça rentrait un peu plus dans le
vif du sujet ça met un peu plus de
pression au centre pour recevoir
donc la tour en V1 c'est toujours un
coup utile de toute façon la tour mieux
placé en 1 quand F1 elle libère aussi la
casse pour le cavalier et ça crée un
vis-à-vis face à la dame on se fait
beaucoup de choses donc Magnus a choisi
fou en D8 donc l'idée c'est
éventuellement de remplacer le fou de ce
côté mais surtout de laisser la case de
7 dispo pour un cavalier qui pourra
revenir chasser ce fou des cinq donc
lutter pour pour l'important de caisse
des 5 qui est finalement un trou dans la
position des Noirs qui actuellement
utilisé par par ce fou blanc
et donc je m'attends à ce qu'ils mettent
peut-être un Cavaillon E7 je sais pas
lequel
j'ai peut-être
mais ça pourrait être l'autre aussi
évidemment l'autre qui avait allié
il couvrait plus à Casa 7 mais on pour
l'instant je sais pas trop ce qu'une
tour Eiffel là-bas pour être assez
facilement donc ça pose pas trop de
problèmes c'est à dire ce qu'il a choisi
comme c'est top et maintenant il faut
des cinq et attaquer par le cavalier je
pense que il le prendrait bien s'il
avait l'occasion avec les Noirs les
Blancs reprendrai bien sûr il perdent
rien mais ça prendrait la paire de fou
et ensuite et 5 ou quoi pour arriver
donc sûrement que ce fou va être
contraint de reculer
voilà c'est fait il va en B3
les Magnus qui pourrait peut-être jouer
un peu un crochet tf5 quoi qu'il en soit
ou simplement faut aussi pour pour
mettre un fond en face de l'autre et en
fait une dernière option c'est peut-être
juste de jouer fou B7 pour essayer de
percer au centre mais c'est toujours
difficile à ce coup des 5 tant que ce
pion n'est pas soutenu donc ça a l'air
d'être un plan un peu plus dur à
mettre en place
donc peut-être peut-être plutôt du Fou
aussi tranquille ou
un coup comme hache 6 pour être jouable
pas méga indispensable mais ça évitera
toute velléité avec du kij5 qui
arriverait et qui pourra laisser place
aussi à la dame arrive à faire au H8 en
tout cas il s'enlève de cette diagonale
donc c'est un coup clairement logique et
les Noirs comptent comptent envoyer du
FCO dès que possible
5 qui serait clairement un coup qui
améliorait leur cas qui général de
l'espace qui pourrait cloisonner le
fouet 3 en suite c'est pas un trait au
fou ensuite devenir par là-bas et
peut-être une avalanche d'options à
aller droit c'est pas un plan à prendre
à la légère côté blanc
et pareil si sur F5 les blancs venaient
à prendre bah ça aiderait les noirs qui
pourraient se reprendre avec le fou soit
même avec le cavalier qui rebondirait
que ça très bien placé et surtout on a
d'ailleurs plus de pions plus de pions
sans trop pour l'instant car le scène
qui récite sa partition regarde bien
connaître ses plans
peut-être une manière de contrarier ça
serait des signes le fameux kg G5
puisque sur un coup comme H6 la dame
pourrait venir en H5 et aussi l'autre
idée sur quel G5 existe option elle
venait à bouger il y aurait du calypsage
7 dans l'air puisque si on reprend un H5
carrément mat il faut pas oublier s'il y
a pas de Pione F la 4g8 serait contrôlé
par le fou et le roi n'aurait plus de
casse de fuite donc peut-être une option
ok G5 je sais pas avoir
sans pas un coup complètement absurde
moins qu'il y a une invitation tactique
directe mais sinon pourquoi pas
en tout cas Fabi qui réfléchit
important il est venu d'un point dans ce
match c'est sa dernière partie avec les
Blancs donc faut essayer de mettre la
pression et surtout pas perdre en même
temps s'il perdait s'en serait fini en
ce match alors bien sûr ce serait pas
fini les espoirs dans le tournoi on
connaît bien sûr ce format particulier
ici ou quand on perd on n'a pas vraiment
perdu parce qu'on revient dans le loser
bracket
mais quand même
donc j'ai 5 jouets en tout cas c'est un
coup qui interdit au pion F de bouger
comme je vous l'ai dit si spion venait à
bouger par exemple F5 elle est même F6
on peut faire qui est pas beau PAF qui
prend H7 et se reprend il y aurait maths
donc j'ai 5 jouets
et ça pourrait suivre bien sûr pendant
H5 quoi agressif
comme Magnus qui réfléchit maintenant à
son tour
mais oui exception elle fait pas bouger
pourquoi pas H6
mais les Blancs ne passent pas grand
chose mais bon juste ils sont en place
il bloque un peu le jeu des noirs
à voir en tout cas ça va être
intéressant ce qui va se passer
si ce match peut se décider dans les
minutes à venir
donc 6 dommage 5 peut-être un coup de
retour du roi ce qui va s'en aller soit
retour F3 soit même en H3 pour peut-être
avoir du F4 par la suite
c'est un peu le principe des échecs
c'est vrai
du coup on attend
peut-être donc un coup comme
on s'attend quand même une démarche 5
qui débarque voilà c'était rapidement
cliqué par Fabiano
la dame qui est cloué ce pion
vas-yves ah bah oui tout le temps à tout
niveau d'ailleurs comme ça tu
recommandes de faire des petits
exercices d'échauffement pour être en
pleine forme ah ouais bien sûr en plus
c'est un conseil que Vlad m'avait donné
donc j'ai pas trop utilisé mais je peux
vous le donner si vous êtes plus
vaillant que moi faites-le quoi et donc
ça pour les conseils
peut-être le petit cahier d'entraînement
que je vois que tu en as les mains
un livre qu'on a de t'entraîner qu'on a
coécrit qui est
des petites idées
quoi dire bah ouais plein d'exercices
des petites anecdotes à travers des quiz
qui apprendront aussi l'histoire des
échecs donc avoir cette curiosité aussi
pour l'histoire connaître les gens du
passé des petits Records qui ont été
battus des choses comme ça et surtout
pas mal d'exercices quasiment 300 je
crois dans le livre
classé par thème qui vont en discuter
croissante donc ça permet de bien
s'échauffer d'arriver à fuer pour les
tournois d'été
donc en complément des puzzles sur
chaisecom évidemment puzzle rush
exactement exactement
parce qu'il faut avoir une vision un peu
de tous ces patterns dans les
reconnaître pas louper des tactiques
quand on a l'opportunité d'en avoir et
pas les laisser à l'adversaire non plus
et de deux s'entraîner au calcul de
toute façon c'est la clé aux échecs
le calcul la puissance de calcul pour
pouvoir se projeter calculer loin de
manière précise ça va évaluer une
position donc voilà ça c'est un
entraînement de toute une vie et qui
qu'on peut toujours améliorer
entraînement quotidien voilà si possible
bien sûr apprenez pas tous pro mais plus
vous le ferez mieux ce sera mieux vous
jouerez plus vous verrez de manière
limpide les positions dans vos calculs
sa condition sinequanone pour devenir
grand maître voilà mais même à des
niveaux inférieurs de toute façon
je pense c'est une des différences
notables en fait entre les différents
niveaux
le supprimer une fois que les Blancs ont
repris fermer la position avec F4 qui
cloisonnerait fou donc fabien a choisi
de prendre ici et je m'attends à ce
qu'ils prennent du cavalier pour
recycler il faisait pas grand chose à
parcourir cette case
et là il sera là il tapera le fou il
permet aussi au fouet à la dame de
courir cette case aussi c'est une fois
qu'il sera un F5 donc ça a l'air je sais
pas sûrement le coup le plus logique des
trois
on va voir comment ça continue de toute
façon ça joue
ce genre tu penses sont fatigués ou là
deux heures de jeu tout simplement dans
l'eau ça va je pense qu'ils sont en
pleine forme
après on est pas sûr que est-ce qu'on
est vraiment sûr que son
boîtier souvent la pièce dans laquelle
il joue ah mais ça j'en sais rien
effectivement je sais pas trop
d'ailleurs je vois que le CO2 a baissé
dans l'air il doit peut-être moins
respirer je sais pas moins diffuser de
CO2
par le nez
donc il a bien pris du cavalier Fabien
qui est reparti en quatre avec son
cavalier
et donc voilà on a cette position là
[Musique]
équilibrée j'ai envie de dire
où tout peut aller très vite pour
l'instant les deux jambes bien joué
mais a priori il y a un prendre la paire
de fou ce serait pas forcément une
grande idée côté noir parce qu'on
ramènerait ce qu'elle est F1 qui sautera
en E3 et qui pourrait ensuite venir vers
la belle case des 5 et il y aurait deux
qui avaient les centraux dans le 4 et
donc l'autre en trois pour l'instant qui
serait pas mal on vaut mieux pas toucher
à cette perte fou et
je sais pas faire autre chose peut-être
il faut aussi on se développe on échange
de fouet 3 qui est quand même assez
pénible
et bien sûr un coup comme comme vous
c'est ça aussi on peut ils sont gênés
simplement redécole fou pour défendre un
peu spion des 6 un pion clef dans cette
chaîne de pions la base l'édifice de
l'édifice dans la position noire
donc voilà plusieurs coins envisageables
et sûrement plus ou moins de même valeur
après Magnus de se décider de faire le
bon choix le temps pour être impactant
c'est parti comme toujours 6 minutes
quand même
[Musique]
vite tourner vinaigre
donc il a choisi fou B7 un autre coup je
n'avais pas mentionné mais qui développe
également le fou qui le place sur la
grande diagonale
donc forcément il est pas mal
mais ce qui est bon souvent dans ces
structures là que c'est triangles sans
trop on l'avait vu en jouer des fois
dans des Antilles chez sneakers
dans la littérature classique simplement
parce que ça fait un gros trou ici ça
fait un mauvais fou il faut dire quand
même qu'il y a un beau contrôle au
centre et si on arrive à maîtriser quand
même la case pas laisser les blancs
s'installer voire même pousser un jour
ou faire les bons échanges de pièces ben
ça peut être pas mal et
ça se voit qu'il comprend bien en fait
ce qui se passe dans ces positions là
alors pas que dans celle-là bien sûr
mais c'est genre peut-être le plus grand
spécialiste là-dedans quoi
après plus grande spécialiste pas que
là-dedans non dans plein de choses
simplement il est plus fort et tout
ouais mais après chaque fois tu as des
positions que tu joues mieux que
d'autres et puis là c'est un peu
novateur entre guillemets quoi de se
complaire dans une genre de choses cinq
ça avait été un choc ça partie compte
Maxime à la sinclofield je crois
ou
les pions tout pourri quoi c'est 5 ou 5
G5 je crois il a fait que les prout il
avait tout comblé il est tout comblé
très très facilement alors il y avait
une île mais je veux dire limite à un
moment ça a même été lui qui aurait pu
être mieux symboliquement on va dire
alors ça ressemble à rien quoi tu aurais
cru un débutant qui jouait c'était
dégueulasse j'aurais un élève qui joue
comme ça
après ça devait être tout analyser mais
donc depuis ça a été un peu une
révolution on va dire non dans la
manière de voir ces choses là cette
structure
c'est pas mal
donc c'est le coup le plus logique
exactement
je suis complètement d'accord un coup
normal naturel sain logique
et jouer la pièce qui joue le moins
bah ouais enfin un truc très concret à
faire et pourquoi pas le faire soit
[Musique]
soit
sinon c'est bien de remplacer ses pièces
qui font rien parce que elles pourront
jouer par la suite plus tard
alors tu m'avais parlé de Oslo pour ce
tournoi je vais demander s'il était en
hybride ou pas c'est les commentaires
qui ont lieu depuis Oslo je me suis un
petit peu renseigné là pendant la pause
donc les commentaires sont hybrides mais
c'est tout les joueurs sont chez eux
chez eux mais les commentaires d'après
ce que j'ai compris sont dans un studio
à Oslo
ok
Cup dans le principe
c'est spectaculaire comme idée ouais ok
de chez eux ils ont tous du bon matériel
et des studios je pensais studios de
cheescom aux USA où il y a des trucs
quoi
Oslo ça peut être le studio européen
pourquoi pas mais mais d'accord
donc bien en carbone des commentaires
pas terrible quoi non ça va parce que
c'est finalement j'ai envie de te dire
non c'est plutôt correct puisque il y a
Tanya sagave qui vient de dinde oui donc
si tu vas jusqu'au États-Unis quelque
part c'est encore pire c'est encore pire
donc c'est un peu le centre ça va donc
ça va vieille H4 bien joué propose de
changer des dames
impose même on voit mal à un dame D1
quand même
pas l'air magnifique comme coup et puis
surtout qui pour ensuite y avoir un
dessin de D4 du coup comme ça côté noir
pour ouvrir la grande diagonale
sans trop d'histoires sans trop de
chichis
mais même Magnus peut-être ses chances
avec les armes parce que bon c'est ça
qui joue bien les finales
et là cette masse centrale qui peut
peut-être avancer un moment je sais pas
on va voir
on va peut-être la voir un savant c'est
sur le centre de l'échiquier
en tout cas pour le moment
pour le moment ça tient bien ça tient
bien à côté noir
pas désarçonner le Viking norvégien
[Musique]
bon je sais pas où ils vont venir en
fait exactement en fait il veut échanger
ramener le fond je sais pas où faire
aussi maintenant ce serait une
possibilité vu que cette case n'est plus
contrôlée
on va regarder le live officiel enfin on
va jeter un œil tu vois je crois qu'ils
sont un studio je veux juste montrer à
femme
c'est peut-être le studio qui avait déjà
les autres années là où il y avait la
présentatrice norvégienne je sais plus
son nom mais ouais
ils sont dans le dans le studio
non mais ça bon on peut pas dire studio
qui est dans le même dans le même esprit
non mais tu es très beau ça c'est pas le
problème
oh c'est fin en fait je veux dire tant
qu'il y avait les commentateurs
européens donc je sais pas les Davido
ouais etc je sais plus trop loin leur
équipe
bon pourquoi pas puis j'imagine c'est un
studio qui devait être financer par par
les Norvégiens mais là de faire venir
les Américains ça me semble un peu loin
quoi
c'est vrai qu'on pourrait échanger ce
cahier pour prendre ce pion mais
attention il y aurait aussi celui-là
derrière c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle se fouille en vessie c'est le
coup C4 je vais pas Magnus c'est de
faire cracher du feu à ce fou en B6
3 donc il veut échanger les fous de case
noire et donc en profiter avec son Cali
central
on peut peut-être plusieurs options pour
les Noirs il pourrait essayer déjà de
liquider en prenant à la fois l'un et
l'autre je sais pas dans quel sens mais
hop ou en refusant l'échange pourquoi
pas pour mieux tenir cette case mais un
coup qui fait un peu je sais pas j'aime
pas trop pousser cette un peu vers
l'arrière alors après c'est foutu 7
couplé à du dessin qui avancerait
pourquoi pas il faudrait pas se
retrouver avec ce fou si mauvais en C7
qui ne bougerait pas
encore une position passionnante Fabien
dans ce match
on n'arrête pas de nous de nous
surprendre
très serré très serré c'est vrai que
Magnus a pris un belle option à partir
c'est pas fait d'avance mais on voit que
les gens ont du mal à se départager
ensuite
et une attaque dans le Tour de France il
est parti rapidement dans la montée il a
pris un point d'avance c'est vraiment ça
se suit c'est essayer de rouler derrière
pour revenir mais bon ce qui est pris
est pris ce qui est pris n'est plus à
prendre
et ça peut être si simple de revenir sur
le groupe de tête qui se relaient bien
d'ailleurs ça sera l'effort
belle étape
française
tous en fait mais ils ont profité qu'en
fait après le peloton est un peu lâché
l'affaire pour revenir mais sinon ça
aurait pu faire de lourds dégâts
et voir un top 10 s'éloigner
de manière certaine
alors il a pris il a pris un cadre voilà
c'est l'option qui semblait tout
liquider
et
on tombe dans une finale de tour un
nouveau deux tour chacun on a déjà vu un
peu ce scénario dans la partie
précédente
terminée en nul et on imagine ça sera
encore le cas ici
après légèrement tâche symbolique pour
Fabiano des 6 un poil faible on va
mettre deux tours pour le défendre et
puis
et puis voilà
puis le roi noir ensuite se ramènera
j'ai 8 F7 aussi
et que le Matra tout ce qui a colmaté il
se passera plus grand chose
merci au revoir
voilà après ça fera le mettre en place
bon je vois pas pourquoi on est un vrai
pas mais
de 30 pour Fabiano
comment ça se
donc la bonne nouvelle c'est que ce
match va pas se finir en trois parties
comme le tour précédent de Magnus
[Musique]
qui va faire son retard il a dû jouer
une Sicilienne vu le type de position
donc il a pas renouvelé le 4 5
et
il se fait attaquer un peu
[Musique]
désolé on est plus le bon set up c'était
pas rendu compte non c'est quand même
plus joli comme ça
on avait envoyé la partie en fait
quoique peut-être ça a été que c'est
enlever tout seul
ça pourrait faire nuit les
malheureusement ça qui était bien et qui
pourrait nous priver d'une quatrième
partie dans ce match voilà mais alors
bon c'est pas trop déçu on aura une
quatrième partie ici quoi qu'il en soit
j'espère c'est vraiment jamais j'aurais
préféré assurer une quatrième partie à
100%
rassure-toi
en plus ça va ça menuiserait les chances
d'avoir un Armageddon
c'est vrai que c'est beau
il se joue beaucoup dans ses enchères
vous faites très malins
il va prendre la main choisir la couleur
qu'on veut
mais sans faire trop de concessions au
niveau pendule
c'est un oui
bon finalement
on décide c'est lui qui se trouve un peu
passif
à défendre
ce pion B2 qui pourrait même la perdre
et nous priver du quatrième partie
imagine imagine victoire de Magnus ici
victoire de naudirac à côté et là d'où
froide quoi
trois parties
il serait que 21h40 peut-être à ce
moment-là et privé de dessert quoi
rassure-toi Fabien rassure-toi
ça va tenir
en espérant
beau bras de fer
dans la dernière et ultime partie
peut-être peut-être
rien n'est moins sûr
tomber trois jouets
c'est pas mal de coup pour les blancs
mais bon stop si simple à jouer
puisqu'il réfléchit pour ces deux il
attaque le pion C4
qui défendu
immédiatement
c'est quoi cette histoire qui a été de
là c'est le boîtier Racing qui contrôle
l'air chez toi
alors il te permet de savoir que tu as
une mauvaise qualité d'air après faut-il
encore et remédier voilà
exactement au moins tu le sais après
après faut voir s'il y a trop d'humidité
peut-être une des humidificateurs s'il
fait trop chaud bah faut refroidir ça
fait trop froid bah faut chauffer
pas évident tout ça
encore ce soir on le comprend beaucoup
de suspensions dans les enchères là pour
pour décider les temps ah mais je suis
d'accord avec lui c'est vrai que ça
serait dommage aujourd'hui quand on en
soit privé on a quand même eu un camion
ça nous a fait plaisir et il tour Isaac
ça répète les couilles je crois ça va
faire nul malheureusement
malheureusement Fabien Fabiano qui ne
s'impose pas avec les Blancs qui devra
tout donner dans la dernière ronde
et on compte sur lui
dis courageuse avec seulement 14
secondes à la pendule ah mais il
faudrait pas s'amuser à faire ça et
perdre
ce serait la catastrophe si c'était
couplé avec une défaite
de Levon
soit très bien
on ne l'espère évidemment pas
loin de là
mais bon je crois qu'ils vont quand même
peut-être répéter malgré tout attention
il va essayer du G4 G5 tours
mais le ranger il va tout donner
se prend encore des échecs
un petit tour de carrousel minus qui le
pourchasse de partout
des 7 tour des trois après pour faire G5
côté nord pour l'instant c'était pas
trop possible parce que toi aussi c'est
chèque et il devrait faire j'ai 5
peut-être pour se délivrer
si besoin
maintenant
tu auras coupé sur la première
allez on va aller jeter un petit œil de
l'autre côté espérant un retour en force
dans les Van
position complexe
on peut rêver d'une victoire de Levan et
d'une égalisation dans ce deuxième match
Fabien peut-être en tout cas il y a le
fou B2 qui bien active qui peut aider
une dame là-bas mais bon ça a l'air
quasiment gagnant pour aller noir non et
là depuis en plus ouais mais sur dame C3
j'ai une qui veut faire le 5 qui
débarque qu'est-ce qui se passe sur le
prend
peut-être juste vous prend et on pilonne
trop aussi c'est inattendu ce que j'ai 4
mais
joli coup après
étonnant
impressionnant nous dire Beck alors
c'est un joli coup après c'est pas un
coup forcément qui nous arrange non non
il y a plus que 10 secondes pour les
bonnes attention allez il a pris ranger
c'est attaque aussi de voir la fin de ce
match du coup
ça
tort là
il y a quand même la déception qui
prévaut on a vu un joli coup mais
mettons bien sûr finalement
tu joues tout tempo
5 tu reprends le 7 tu prends tout quoi
[Musique]
incroyable
quel combo
et ça gagne ça en est terminé espérons
espérons que Fabiano ne perde pas
maintenant
eh bien il faut vraiment qu'il tienne la
nul là donc en tout cas qualification de
nos Dirk à 12 ans pour la finale du
Winner Bracket
ça c'est fait et qui va l'attendre en
finale est-ce que ça sera Magnus est-ce
que ça sera Fabiano c'est à son comble
rien qui doit tenter le tout pour le
tout avec les Noirs il aura du mal
mais
tu espères
allez
nous faut absolument au moins une nul
avec les Blancs
ça semble lactée mais il faut éviter une
gaffe un mystique et ouais
hâte de voir
qui sera dans l'obligation et qui
tentera de sauver le demi point c'est
jamais facile
surtout avec les Blancs
voir rêver d'une victoire et pourquoi
pas lui exactement Maxime
pourquoi pas une victoire de Fabiano ici
ah de cette partie bien sûr
qui pourrait collecter les deux pions ou
sont les trois si jamais on arrive à
mettre en place un roi blanc
ça joue le pat
ro qui est peut-être retourner vers H2
menacé j'ai trois maths
on va voir
peut-être une déco
extraordinaire une déco ici
alors comment est-ce qu'on peut gagner
côté
sans compliquer quand même
pas évident
ça peut faire une position attention
je crois que tu as eu de Tanger
quand même il y aura quand même une
quatrième partie donc on se retrouve
très vite pour le dénouement de cette
journée extraordinaire encore des
chèques se retrouvent dans une petite
dizaine de minutes à tout de suite
[Musique]
et on est de retour les amis on
regardait un peu le show en anglais pour
se faire une impression ce qui se
passait ouais ils sont bien c'est bien
les studios à Oslo hein
sur le plateau
et donc là pour cette dernière partie
Fabiano qui est absolument besoin de
gagner avec les noirs qui jouent une
sorte de méthode Ruiz mais là ok alors
a-t-il lu le livre il fait baisser un
coup de bêtises
4 h 5 merci au revoir
il y a pas de stratégie d'antiges du
tout quoi c'est terrible
c'est la méthode rise au professionnel
voilà ça H4 non
après Magnus peut juste la jouer très
calme disons de toute façon moi je bouge
pas tu es sur trois rangées
tu dois gagner débrouille-toi quoi moi
il défend bien le pion E4 et il peut
justement soutenir l'avancée d'un pion h
c'est bien tout ça
de gagner
après voilà après être en danger d'être
éliminé pour de vrai quoi
ce serait bien dommage de perdre Fabien
de ce tournoi en tout cas d'où ça t'a
offre
a l'air vraiment bien fort dans ce dans
ce tournoi
du coup H4 H6 comme ça sur H5 il veut
bloquer avec
avec G5
mais bon tu peux quand même faire H5 G5
et sacrifié
tu vas prendre et à
et venir en D6 éventuellement ouais puis
ça aide aussi à faire des dames des deux
pour aller presser sur H6 jouer tout
radin
donc
plus ou moins bien comme quoi
c'est possible
donc
des deux
au moins ça attaquera pas 6
et comme c'est beaucoup mieux dans les
commentateurs en live que les joueurs
logiques
enfin en live je sais pas je pense qu'il
y a pas d'audience non il y a pas
d'audience
pour avoir fait avoir fait la décaper
tout c'est hyper bien non mais je vois
que ils ont tous les sons qui captent
sans micro etc ils ont un truc c'est
nettement mieux que la backup
donc c'est beau
mais oui c'est que un studio
après bon moi de toute façon je suis
toujours parti ils ont de l'hybride
juste pour que tu puisses avoir un oeil
sur les joueurs quand même ça a toujours
de certains doutes voilà pourquoi ils
sont tellement forts moi c'est un peu
comme comme au vélo tu vois je serai
pour enlever les contrôles antidopage
sur les meilleurs
pourquoi pas
pourquoi ils ont intérêt à se doper je
pensais le déval en dessous qui peut se
doper pas les tous meilleurs c'est de
remonter à leur niveau aux autres mais
si tu es dans un genre Amstrong pourquoi
il serait dopé tu gagnes chaque année
paraît bête
pour pas grand chose non je pense faut
division 2 divisions 3 il faudrait
peut-être les faire venir sur place pour
être sûr et puis division bon
c'est les meilleurs au moins tu es sûr
ça peut pas
trop risqué bien sûr donc là dessus il
peut pas y avoir de problème de triche
ça ça me paraît
absolument impossible
il faut être sérieux Fabien
il faut un petit peu de sérieux monsieur
alors des cinq jouets
au centre il vient à l'impact
il a l'air bien ouais on va remettre le
fond c'est de après il va taper fort
le cavalier après
du fou mais ça se trouve c'est bien du
foot mais en prenant de eh ben il a pris
du coup voilà
pour libérer voilà que ce soit la
diagonale ou la case de 4 pour le
cavalier mais il a pris comme ça alors
cela dit sur qu'il prend des seins qui
veut peut-être prendre un an et donc
le but c'était pas du tout de mettre un
foncé deux mais simplement de jouer un
peu qu'on se fout B7 et aussi taper sur
sur des 6
vélos alors ça dépend les équipes qui
gagnent jamais peut-être parce qu'elle
pourrait être tentée de mettre des
petits moteurs dans les roues mais
surtout pas des des équipes leaders ça
ce serait
pas avoir de doute sur les meilleures
équipes n'aurait pas intérêt de perdre
leur réputation pour gagner des courses
légèrement la rotation peut-être
légèrement beaucoup exactement
il prendrait le risque de se doper
ce serait débile de sa part
honnêtement
tellement risqué
prestations précédentes
peut être intéressant pour les puntos
c'est toujours contre deux pièces
et
donc voici l'histoire de sacrifice de
Tours contre fin de deux pièces entre
une tour
ça donne des positions compliquées
[Musique]
intéressante car en tout cas
même on peut dire
peut-être une partie excellente
pas de
j'aurais bien tenté quand même dans ce
dans cette situation de
la joue un peu à la Wesley Sow l'autre
jour
alors que évidemment il aurait peut-être
pu essayer plus dans la position qu'il
avait
il dit je vais contrôler après c'est
souvent son approche là pour le coup
vers le nombre de fois où les dernières
rondes de champion du monde il a juste
fait nul dès qu'il pouvait mais il y
arrive
j'ai jamais vu perdre en faisant ce
genre de choses
super
en tout cas je disais qu'il avait un
ouais un très beau studio
en fait tout à l'heure
quels j'ai pas exactement je crois que
c'est 30 000 pour le premier en tout il
y a 200000 dollars de prix pour ce
tournoi
j'ai pas mal
c'est pas mal du tout d'ailleurs
il y en a pas qu'un dans l'année il y en
a six soya il y a à peu près un million
200000 de prix au total sur sur l'année
[Musique]
après je sais plus oh sûrement 20 pour
le second ça va descendre gentiment
il devrait pas la perdre comme ça là
la possibilité de rendre ton matériel
pour un peu simplifier ce qui fait qu'en
fait
on est trois qui s'infiltre dans le
verre attaque le pion C3
sur mon tour 3 pour échanger
déjà
2003 bah elle est tape
encore partie du peloton des
professionnels à ce moment-là
c'est faire des petites
il a perdu
[Musique]
maman elle va te faire un chocolat chaud
puis papa il va partir faire je t'aime
pas
extraordinaire
il te dit attendez attendez là c'est
encore le plus beau de l'État
tu te rends compte
tout seul il se foutait de l'eau dans la
gueule
bah non
mais comment il avait fait c'est
incroyable de faire ça
il se fait complètement défoncer ils
vont lui on sait qu'il était chargé
quand même annuler
il y avait comment il s'appelait celui
qui a fait battre son une année en
espagnol
j'ai plus sur mon Maxime va l'avoir
c'est sûr
il va dire ça me paraît très évident
il y a aussi à Milton qui avait fait le
tour de France et il fait 5e ou 4e du
Tour de France avec une clavicule cassée
[Rires]
la différence entre la tour des trois
tout à l'heure et celle de maintenant
s'il y a plus de tour en 8 et donc ce
cavalier peut bondir en 5 intercepter
l'attaque sur 3
sur ces trois pardon et dégager
c'était très très fort
de plus
finalement
juste l'apparition probable des foot que
le reposer pour au cas où un bien bien
tout sécurisé
il y a plus de il y a plus de partie là
maintenant
il y a aussi un gars alors il avait saut
d'hamstrong de stopper et du coup dès
qu'il s'échappait
toi il était dégoûté
dedans du coup enfin
ah il y a des trucs du vélo ça
ouais bon il y a plus de partie c'est
terminé là c'est ça tout prend c'est 5
c'est Ciao
maîtrise finalement jamais en danger du
match
on n'a pas l'impression qu'il ait joué à
fond
ça évitera toute vérité d'une tour en D2
ou quoi que ce soit
ça
plus aucun intérêt donc il évite faut ça
mais ne crains aucune menace si les gens
sont plus de moi
et il est obligé de gagner
il est obligé de gagner
c'est 4 qui nous fixe un petit pion
c'est 5
ciao Bambi Noël Ciao
qui vient d'une rencontre entre Lucky
Luciano et les parents de la mafia
alors lequel c'était le capot des CAPI
de toutes les CAPI mais je sais plus
lequel lui a dit ça
petit quoi ouais il avait répondu il y a
qu'une seule personne qui peut m'appeler
Bambino sur cette terre et c'est mon
père
pour poser quand même deux trois bases
assez solide
un peu blanc
trois pions
d'abandonner
non mais ça aurait été une très belle
journée d'échec encore aujourd'hui grâce
à ce champion de chaise tours on est
impatient d'être demain Fabien avec la
grande finale entre Magnus et grande
finale
bien sûr vous savez
un petit peu particulier
on commencera de Harlem
mise en bouche alors je sais pas dans
quel sens ça sera mon ira voir les
tableaux bien évidemment après ça mais
donc on aura Fabiano on aura leven on
aura historique saga et on aura Wesley
Sow
attention à Wesley
aujourd'hui donc il y a cette habitude
de jouer avec c'était Damoclès au-dessus
de la tête
S
c'est quoi la finale des loosers en fait
c'est la fin que ce sera d'où ça vient
bien sûr j'ai oublié ce détail ça va
être extraordinaire
bon la partie se passerait il y a trois
pions
qu'il attendait il nous a dit
j'ai la failli poser des congés pour
pouvoir la suivre à fond les RTT à fond
même des congés sans solde quoi
un sacrif des pions et pour surtout pas
ôter le pain de la bouche et nous
enlever
du spectacle
il veut fout des cinq encore une idée de
marlou
et j'ai quatre
nul
et ben merci à tous d'avoir suivi on se
retrouvera donc demain 17h pour la suite
du tournoi à passer une excellente
soirée ciao ciao
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surpris a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechestre
ou les title Tuesday
chase.com/aventure tous les plus grands
tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages